Here's how I make a tuna sandwich. I take the celery sticks, I chop, chop, chop, chop, I put them in the bowl before the tuna goes in, then I put the tuna in. Here's how I make a tuna fish sandwich. I open up the can of tuna, I put it in a bowl, I slice up the celery. It has to have celery, it cannot have celery.
我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我拿过西芹，切，切，切，切，在金枪鱼放进去之前把它们放进碗里，然后再放入金枪鱼。我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我打开一罐金枪鱼，把它倒进碗里，把西芹切成片。里面必须有西芹，里面不能没有西芹。
Cannot not have celery. Here's how I make a tuna fish sandwich. I open the can of tuna. Two cans. Here's how I make a tuna fish can of it. Here's how I make a tuna fish sandwich. I open up two cans of sa- Here's how I make a tuna fish sandwich. I opened the can at Tuna. Two cans. Here's how I make a tuna fish can. Here's how I make a tuna fish sandwich. I opened up two cans of sa- Here's how I make a tuna fish sandwich. I opened up two cans
不能没有西芹。我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我打开金枪鱼罐头。两罐。我是这样制作金枪鱼罐头的。我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我打开了两罐sa——我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我打开了金枪鱼罐头。两罐。我是这样制作金枪鱼罐头的。我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我打开了两罐sa——我是这样制作金枪鱼三明治的。我打开了两罐
of tuna in water, not oil. It has to be water. Oil's disgusting. And then you put it in the bowl and you, uh, I chop up a celery stick really, really fast. Stup, stup, stup. Super like d- Ah, fuck it, welcome to SmartLives. Smart, less. Smart, less. Smart, less. You heard about Bennett, you know, that he's doing some personal training now. Do you know about this? You're late to the bit.
水浸金枪鱼，不要油浸的。必须是水浸的。油浸的太恶心了。然后你把它放进碗里，你，呃，我把西芹切得非常非常快。笃，笃，笃。超级像d——啊，去他的，欢迎来到SmartLess。Smart，Less。Smart，Less。Smart，Less。你听说本特了吧，你知道他现在在做私人教练。你知道这事吗？你消息真落伍。
You know, some of us get on a little bit early and make sure our devices are working. I like that. It's a good bit. It's proven as a good bit. What time is your next session? I've got one in 9.45 if we could start wrapping this one up, please. What are you talking about? For sure.
你知道的，我们中有的人会早一点上线，确保我们的设备正常运作。我喜欢这样。这挺有一套的。这证明是个好点子。你的下一场咨询是什么时候？我9点45分有一场，如果我们能把这场收尾的话，求你了。你在说什么呢？当然。
There he is. Sean, we could have you start stretching, please. And Chaturanga. Surprise guests, give us a little snap if you don't mind. Oh, nice. Sean, can you hear us? Yes, I can. Sean, do you know what Bennett's background is?
他来了。肖恩，能请你开始拉伸吗？还有四角跪姿。神秘嘉宾，如果不介意的话，给我们拍张照吧。哦，不错。肖恩，你能听到我们说话吗？听得到，我能听到。肖恩，你知道本特的背景是什么吗？
Really quick, do you know what that is? It looks like a gym. Okay. Huh. You're reading books, I see. Yeah, you've seen pictures of us. Somebody's seen pictures of stuff. So Will is back from Georgia.
简单说一下，你知道那是什么吗？看起来像个健身房。好吧。哼。我看到你在看书。对，你见过我们的照片。有人见过东西的照片。所以威尔从佐治亚回来了。
I know, when did you get back, Will? Yesterday. That's cool. And yeah. Are you checking your texts? You wanna get back to us? Yeah, just, is that cool? We can just hold the recorder record?
我知道，你什么时候回来的，威尔？昨天。那挺酷的。还有，对。你在看短信吗？你想回复我们吗？对，只是，这样可以吗？我们能就这么录着音吗？
Somebody's calling me, so I'm trying to think like, why am I do not disturb? Didn't work, but guys, hey, I did have, we flew back yesterday and had some crazy turbulence early into the flight. Wow, I knew love turbulence. And it was the, maybe the worst I've ever had. And it was like, it was scary AF. And the rest of the flight I was just,
有人在给我打电话，所以我一直在想，为什么我的“请勿打扰”模式没起作用呢？但是，伙计们，嘿，我确实，我们昨天飞回来，在航班刚开始时遇到了疯狂的气流。哇，我以前可喜欢气流了。而且那是，可能是我经历过最糟糕的一次。简直是，吓死宝宝了。接下来的航程我一直在，
the cortisol dump that I had from that was just so intense. It was like one of those side to side and up and down. And being alone is scary too, because I'm sure you were alone. Well, I was flying. Oh, so you were up front. I flew myself, yeah, I was up front. So I was really scared,
那次经历产生的皮质醇让我感到非常强烈。就像那种左右摇晃、上下颠簸的感觉。而且一个人待着也很可怕，因为我确信你当时是一个人。嗯，我在开飞机。哦，所以你在前排。我自己开的飞机，对，我在前排。所以我真的很害怕，
because also I don't know how to fly a plane. Yeah. Do you get really, do you get really scared about turbulence? Yeah, do yeah? Yeah, hang on a second you guys talk about all your world travels You know don't remember Flying next to this old old gal. Oh, that's right. Yeah, that's right. I forgot you know that I am and just I love to dig her fingers into your arm next to her She white knuckles it all the way If you don't bring a white Russian in time, you're gonna get some fingernails. Oh
因为我也不知道怎么开飞机。对。你真的很，你对气流感到非常害怕吗？对，真的吗？对，等一下，你们聊了那么多世界旅行的事情，你知道吗？不记得坐在旁边这个老太太旁边了。哦，对哦。对，没错。我忘了你知道我是，而且我就是喜欢把手指陷进她旁边你的胳膊里。她全程都紧张得指关节发白。如果你不及时拿来一杯白俄罗斯鸡尾酒，你就要挨指甲挠了。哦，
listen, I Was just like at that point anything was on the table. Yeah, but was it like gaspy was it were you? Yeah, it was just me it was me and Eli and her buddy Bob and Liz But was it like Gaspie? Was it, were you? We were like, oh yeah. And it was just me, it was me and Eli and everybody, Bob and Liz. Yeah, that's very. And the plane, and it was. And everybody ends up just closing their eyes
听着，我当时觉得任何办法都可以接受。对，但那是那种倒吸气的吗？是，你是吗？对，只有我，我和伊莱还有她的好友鲍勃和莉兹。但那是那种倒吸气的吗？那是，你是吗？我们当时就像，哦，对。而且只有我，我和伊莱还有大家，鲍勃和莉兹。对，非常。还有飞机，而且是。最后每个人都闭上了眼睛，
and not talking. Yeah, nobody talked, it got really, you know, it gets weird. Are they as nervous flyers as you are? Or were they more casual? No, but I think that everybody plays a role once somebody is the most nervous then everybody else can be degrees of less. No, but I think that everybody plays a role once somebody is the most nervous, then everybody else can be degrees of less.
一言不发。对，谁也没说话，气氛变得很诡异，你知道的。他们和你一样是容易紧张的乘客吗？还是他们更随性一些？不，但我觉得每个人都在扮演一个角色，一旦有人表现得最紧张，那么其他人就可以稍微不那么紧张一点。不，但我觉得每个人都在扮演一个角色，一旦有人表现得最紧张，那么其他人就可以稍微不那么紧张一点。
Yeah, yeah. And I was definitely the worst. I've been better lately, but that one, yesterday, and the guy had said to us like, look, there's gonna be some pretty, it's gonna be pretty choppy early on. I didn't think that he meant- Did you say choppy?
对，对。而且我绝对是最糟糕的。我最近状况好多了，但昨天那次，那个人跟我们说，听着，等下会有相当，一开始会相当颠簸。我没想到他的意思是——你刚才说颠簸吗？
He said pretty choppy, yeah, because I wanted to get it wet choppy. We got it, good. He's wanted to get it wet chappy. We got it. He's in. Pretty chappy early on. Anyway, it was one of those like, you know, please don't let this be the moment. All that kind of shit.
他说相当颠簸，对，因为我想让它湿润颠簸。我们懂了，很好。他想让它湿润颠簸。我们懂了。他加入了。一开始相当颠簸。不管怎样，那是那种，你知道的，“请别让这成为最后一刻”的时刻。诸如此类的鬼话。
And yeah. Did you send off any texts to any family members? I couldn't, I couldn't even reach for my, are you kidding? He's doing it now. He was doing it at the beginning of the show. You know, well, the funny thing about it is it's, it's the control too. So it's like looking at the window holding on
还有。你有没有给任何家人发短信？我不能，我都够不到我的，你在开玩笑吗？他现在就在发。他在节目刚开始的时候就在发。你知道的，嗯，关于这件事有趣的地方在于，这也是关于控制欲。所以这就好比看着窗户，紧紧抓着，
is if like my worry or looking at the, or any of it's gonna have any effect on the outcome. Like if I grab the thing with the chair really hard, it'll brace my fall. Have you thought about hypnosis at all? I have, I have. And I know our friend, she did it, right? Yeah, and it works for her.
就好像我的担心或看着，或者其中的任何事情会对结果产生什么影响一样。就好像如果我死死抓住椅子的某个东西，就能缓冲我的下坠。你想过催眠吗？我想过，我想过。而且我知道我们的朋友，她做过，对吧？对，对她管用。
Does it? Well, Yeah, and it works. Well, that does it. Well, it's gonna be worse. So. What about, but Hypnosis, you guys ever done Hypnosis? You ever been? Yeah, I did guided Hypnosis or something, but I didn't really, I don't know.
管用吗？嗯，对，而且管用。好吧，那就这样。好吧，那会更糟糕。所以。那，但是催眠，你们做过催眠吗？你们去过吗？对，我做过引导催眠什么的，但我真的不知道。
Where were you trying to do? Do we go for guesses? Eliminate marshmallows from your diet. And it was half successful. Now he's just doing the mini ones. Drinking hot cocoa so it didn't work. Are you really drinking hot? Are you having hot cocoa right now?
你当时想去哪？我们来猜猜？从你的饮食中戒掉棉花糖。这半成功了。现在他只吃迷你的了。喝热可可，所以没用。你真的在喝热吗？你现在在喝热可可吗？
Yeah, right now. Here's the thing. I know it's like every day it's a 11 year old's birthday party. He truly is one of Santa's elves. I think that's who Sean is. Wait, what Sean, what was it? Last night I flew, I went out yesterday
对，就现在。事情是这样的。我知道这感觉就像每天都是11岁小孩的生日派对。他真的就像圣诞老人的小精灵之一。我想肖恩就是那样的人。等等，什么肖恩，是什么？昨昨晚我飞了，我昨天出发，
and came back last night to Vegas to see you two at the speeder. Oh wow. Wasn't it, you guys went. Yeah. I didn't go, I didn't, he went. Wasn't that, isn't that the sphere incredible? It's mind blowing.
昨晚回到拉斯维加斯看你们俩在球体馆的演出。哦，哇。不是吗，你们去了。对。我没去，我没去，他去了。难道那，那个球体馆不令人难以置信吗？太震撼了。
It's unbelievable, I don't know how they do that. I saw that picture that you guys posted that you did or Scotty did of you guys with, with Jimmy and Deb and, and Edge. Yeah. Yeah. It's just Edge. Yeah. Oh, sorry. Edge, sorry. Mr. Edge.
太不可思议了，我不知道他们是怎么做到的。我看到了你们发布的照片，你们或斯科蒂拍的你们和吉米、黛布还有The Edge在一起的照片。对。对。只有The Edge。对。哦，抱歉。Edge，抱歉。Edge先生。
Fuck man. Come on. V is not his first name. It is not. No. It's mine. Very cool dude. Yeah, no. The, the Jason Babian.
操，老兄。拜托。V不是他的名。确实不是。不是。是我。非常酷的家伙。对，不。那，那个杰森·巴比安。
They're all, all so great. But anyway, it was great. It was amazing. I can't believe I lost so much money We landed gambled a saw the show came back home. That's how you do it I can't I can't sleep overnight there. It's so depressing. Your game is guess I think will you might know this but listen a listener You guess what Sean Hayes is a game of choice. I think he's mentioned it on the show before but But it's like roulette. He likes roulette and blackjack. Yeah, I was going to say that.
他们都，所有人都太棒了。但不管怎样，太棒了。太令人惊叹了。真不敢相信我输了那么多钱。我们降落，赌博，看演出，然后回家。这就是你们的风格。我不能，我不能在那儿过夜。太令人沮丧了。你们的游戏是，我猜，威尔你可能知道这个，但听着，听众朋友们，你们猜肖恩·海斯的首选游戏是什么。我想他以前在节目里提到过，但是，但就像轮盘赌。他喜欢轮盘赌和二十一点。对，我刚想这么说。
Yeah. Oh, is that our guess? I hope that's our guess. Well, why don't we come? Why don't we introduce our guest? Our guest is anxious to get it. We've never had it. We've never... It's the first time that is a guest violation.
对。哦，那是我们的猜测吗？我希望那是我们的猜测。好吧，我们为什么不来？我们为什么不介绍一下我们的嘉宾？我们的嘉宾急不可耐了。我们从来没这样做过。我们从来没……这是违反嘉宾规定的。
Yeah, it's the first one. Could you tell, by the way, could you tell just by the voice? Not yet. I couldn't. But we've started, they've started in the penalty box. Starting in a two minute penalty box, just a minor. Well, my intro's about two minutes, that's perfect. I'm so excited about my guests today.
对，这是第一次。顺便问一下，你们能仅凭声音听出来吗？还不行。我听不出来。但我们已经开始了，他们已经进了禁闭室。刚进两分钟的禁闭室，只是个小罚时。好吧，我的开场白大约有两分钟，这太完美了。我对我今天的嘉宾感到无比兴奋。
They're obviously excited, because they're already on the show, I mean. No, I seriously, I've been trying to get him for a long time. He's considered romcom royalty, but he's also done it all guys, exceptionally well, I've been trying to get him for a long time. He's considered rom-com royalty, but he's also done it all, guys, exceptionally well, I might add. I'm a huge fan, and the best part is, he may be even nicer than me. When he first moved to Los Angeles, he worked as a bartender for nearly a decade. Over the years, he's become a very effective environmental activist fighting for, amongst other things, climate change and a zillion other things. Ed Begley Jr., The Rom-Com King.
他们显然也很兴奋，因为他们已经上节目了，我是说。不，说真的，我请他很久了。他被视为浪漫喜剧界的王室成员，但他各方面都做得极其出色，伙计们，我必须补充一句，我请他很久了。他被视为浪漫喜剧界的王室成员，但他各方面都做得极其出色，伙计们，我必须补充一句。我是他的超级粉丝，最棒的是，他可能比我还友善。他刚搬到洛杉矶时，当了近十年的调酒师。多年来，他成为了一名非常高效的环境活动家，为气候变化以及无数其他事业而战。小埃德·贝格利，浪漫喜剧之王。
Harry Toms, us is exciting. Ed Begley Jr. Who I love actually by the way. I'm such a fan of this person. I can't wait for you to see who it is. You're gonna love him. One of his characters makes me green with envy. Jim Carrey? Whatever I think of how to spell or say his name,
哈里·汤姆斯，我们太兴奋了。小埃德·贝格利。其实我顺便说一句，我很喜欢他。我是这个人的超级粉丝。我等不及要让你们看看他是谁了。你们会喜欢他的。他的一个角色让我嫉妒得发绿。金·凯瑞？每当我想到怎么拼写或念他的名字，
I always think of the word buffalo. It's my hero, Mark Ruffalo. Oh, Mark. Ta-da. Yeah. Of course I broke the rules. Wait, Ruffalo, are you a romcom king? Is that your-
我总是会想到“水牛”这个词。我的英雄，马克·鲁法洛。哦，马克。 Tada。对。我当然破坏了规则。等等，鲁法洛，你是浪漫喜剧之王吗？那是你的——
I was gonna go with Hugh Grant or- I know, there's- No, you've done obviously amazing, dramatic work, but I love your romcoms. Thank you. Yeah. Mark, look, we've got matching Peepers on I Yeah, what else can I use here? Do I have anything else?
我本想说休·格兰特或者——我知道，有——不，你显然做过令人惊叹的戏剧表演，但我爱死你的浪漫喜剧了。谢谢。对。马克，听着，我们戴着同款眼镜。我，我这里还能用什么？我还有别的吗？
Mark did I just see you got nominated yesterday critics choice award? Maybe something like that? Um the national board of review national Who's counting? Yeah, I mean, but I am a New Yorker, so you know, I had a shoe win. Mark Ruffalo, dude, welcome. Will, Mark. Will and I go way back. Do you know that? No, tell me how.
马克，我刚刚是不是看到你昨天获得了评论家选择奖的提名？也许类似这样的奖项？嗯，国家评论协会，国家……谁在数这个？对，我是说，但我是个纽约人，所以你知道的，我稳操胜券。马克·鲁法洛，老兄，欢迎。威尔，马克。我和马克是老交情了。你知道吗？不，告诉我怎么个老交情法。
I mean, like mid 90s, early 90s. I bet you can give us the month, Willie. Yeah. Well, yeah, they, how about this? Fall of 96 is when you guys did This Is Our Youth. You're unbelievable. You're unbelievable. How do you know that?
我是说，大概是90年代中期，90年代初。我敢打赌你能说出具体月份，威利。对。嗯，对，他们，这样如何？96年秋天，你们演了《这是我们这一代》。你太不可思议了。你太不可思议了。你怎么知道的？
How do you know that? Because, well, because, so Mark did This Is Our Youth with Josh Hamilton and my then girlfriend, Missy Yeager, whom I've talked about. It's a great play. And with that Kenny Larrigan wrote and they did it off-Broadway. What was that theater, Mark?
你怎么知道的？因为，嗯，因为，马克和乔许·汉密尔顿以及我当时的女友米西·耶格尔一起演了《这是我们这一代》，我提过她。这是一部很棒的剧。肯尼斯·罗纳根写的，他们在百老汇之外上演了它。那是哪个剧院，马克？
The first theater you guys did it in. The Intar. The Intar. The Intar. The Intar. And it was like, and Mark and Missy had also done a lot of, I guess it was like Tuesdays at nine that you guys were doing a bunch of scenes that Kenny had written, right?
你们演出的第一个剧院。Inar剧院。Inar。Inar。Inar。而且就像，而且马克和米西也做过很多，我猜大概像是“周二九点”，你们演了肯尼斯写的一堆场景，对吧？
For a few years leading up to it. Yeah, there was some, they had that playwright, naked angels had that short plays at the festival. Yeah. And then they did this. Are you in a closet, Mark? No, this is my office. My wife has the giant room upstairs at the balcony and I'm in what used to be
在此之前的几年里。对，有些，他们有那个剧作家，“赤脚天使”在艺术节上有过短剧。对。然后他们演了这个。马克，你在衣柜里吗？不，这是我的办公室。我太太拥有楼上带阳台的巨大房间，而我待在以前是
a laundry room slash bathroom and where I'm sitting is where the toilet was basically. Wow. It's pretty awesome. Listener it is a wood paneled, it's got beautiful pictures on it but it is narrow. It's New York. It's New York. This is like premium space in New York. I mean people have apartments this it's New York. It's New York. This is like premium space in New York. I mean, people have apartments this size in New York.
洗衣房兼浴室的地方，我坐的地方基本上以前是个马桶。哇。挺棒的。听众朋友们，这是一个木质镶板的房间，上面有漂亮的画，但它很窄。这就是纽约。这就是纽约。这是纽约的黄金地段。我的意思是，人们在纽约有这么大的公寓。这就是纽约。这就是纽约。这是纽约的黄金地段。我的意思是，人们在纽约有这么大的公寓。
I mean. Mark, it's so nice to meet you. I'm so glad you're here. Thank you for doing this. Thank you for bringing me. It's really cool. It's so cool. You're just meeting him and he's your guest.
我是说。马克，很高兴认识你。很高兴你来到这里。谢谢你参与录制。这真的很酷。太酷了。你刚认识他，他就是你的嘉宾。
Will and I both know him. Why are you one of our guests? Yeah, we go back, Jason, and I go back. He's my guest because I'm a big fan. You guys go back? A tiny bit. We don't go back to the intern theater or whatever it was called. I go back. He's my guest because I'm a big fan. You guys go back? A tiny bit. We don't go back to the intern theater or whatever it was called.
威尔和我都很了解他。为什么他是我们的嘉宾？对，我们认识很久了，杰森，我和他认识很久了。他是我的嘉宾，因为我是他的超级粉丝。你们认识很久了？一点点。我们可不认识什么Inar剧院之类的地方。他是我的嘉宾，因为我是他的超级粉丝。你们认识很久了？一点点。我们可不认识什么Inar剧院之类的地方。
In-bar, bro. That's it. Sorry, bro. Come on, bro. But Mark is just, I think I fanned out quite a bit when I met you the first couple of times and I'm kind of fanning out now.
Inar，老兄。就是这样。抱歉，老兄。拜托，老兄。但马克，我想我前几次见到你时真的有点狂热追星了，现在我也依然有点狂热追星。
You're just one of my favorites, Mark. Truly. Oh man, thank you. Coming from you, that's a huge compliment. Thank you, any of you. Thank you, Sean. Just, yeah. I huge compliment. Thank you, any of you. Thank you, Sean. Yeah, I'm excited. Whenever I see Kenneth Lonergan, I have a name,
你绝对是我的最爱之一，马克。真的。哦，天哪，谢谢你。这话从你嘴里说出来，真是极大的赞美。谢谢，你们任何人。谢谢，肖恩。只是，对。极大的赞美。谢谢，你们任何人。谢谢，肖恩。对，我很兴奋。每当我看到肯尼斯·罗纳根的名字，我有个名字，
I was like, I think it's Kenny Loggins at first class, but tell me like how, because Will mentioned... Wait, can we back up into that compliment one more time? Like, whenever I see his name, I'm like, Because Lonergan's just fun in his early grave real quick. No, I know, but I'm just... But wait, this is our youth. First of all, it was a huge hit, and like,
我当时想，我一开始以为是肯尼·罗金斯，但告诉我，因为威尔提到……等等，我们能回到刚才那个赞美再聊一会儿吗？比如，每当我看到他的名字，我就觉得……因为罗纳根简直太……让我们快点跳过吧。不，我知道，但我是说……等等，《这是我们这一代》。首先，这是一部巨大的轰动之作，而且就像，
every actor in the world does scenes from that now. I mean, isn't that wild? My son is doing scenes from it. No way. He's acting class today. Yeah, yeah, every actor does it. How old is he? He's so crazy. He's 22. 22.
现在全世界的演员都在排演里面的片段。我的天，这难道不疯狂吗？我儿子就在排演里面的片段。不会吧。他今天有表演课。对，对，每个演员都在演。他多大了？太疯狂了。他22岁。22岁。
Dude, that is so fucking crazy. So it happens. You guys, you have to understand that when that, when these guys did, this is our youth, when it came out, it was like shot out of a cannon. It took everybody by surprise in this way that you can't believe. People were like, all of them were so,
老兄，这太他妈疯狂了。所以事情就是这样。你们，你们必须明白，当，当这群家伙演出《这是我们这一代》时，当它上映时，它就像从大炮里发射出来一样。它以一种你无法相信的方式让所有人大吃一惊。人们当时觉得，他们所有人都是那么，
I mean, Josh and Missy and Mark, but Mark was so good in this part that people were like tripping over themselves to offer him, they couldn't believe what it was. It was so good and the play is so well written, Mark. You can, you know, speak to that. What a beautiful, right? Beautiful character, so perfect, almost, that play.
我是说，乔许、米西和马克，但马克在这个角色里表现得太棒了，以至于人们争先恐后地想把角色给他，他们简直不敢相信这是真的。太棒了，而且剧本写得太好了，马克。你可以，你知道的，谈谈这一点。多么优美，对吧？美丽的角色，如此完美，几乎可以说是完美的剧本。
Yeah. You wanna hear something crazy? We just did a fundraiser here in New York City, me, Missy and Matt Damon who took the play to London a couple of years after we did it. I had a full white beard. We did a reading. It was basically, it was kind of turned into
你想听件疯狂的事吗？我们刚刚在纽约市举办了一场募款活动，我和米西还有马特·达蒙，他在我们演出几年后把这部剧带到了伦敦。我留着一把浓密的白胡子。我们做了一次剧本朗读。基本上，它有点变成了
the stage reading. Like Missy remembered all her lines. I remembered some of mine. Wow. Of course, Missy remembered all hers. Of course she did, yeah. And Damon was just right there. And literally it was the play.
舞台朗读。比如米西记得她所有的台词。我只记得我的一部分。哇。当然，米西记得她所有的台词。她当然记得，对。而达蒙就在那里。字面意思就是那部剧。
I mean, we had the hat, we had the major Matt Mason. Wow. You know, and it was, it was, you know, it's funny because it just tells you like what you could get away with on stage. People, I think people bought that we were 19, you know? Yeah, right. Even with my big Santa Claus beard.
我是说，我们有帽子，我们有Major Matt Mason。哇。你知道的，而且，这很有趣，因为它告诉你你在舞台上能蒙混过关到什么程度。人们，我想人们相信我们当时只有19岁，你知道吗？对，没错。哪怕我留着大大的圣诞老人胡子。
I'm so jealous I have zero theater history in my, you know, in my history. You would be great in theater, man. I remember reading for a couple in my early 20s in New York and was so nervous to get out on stage and audition for those three silhouettes deep in the house, speaking that you can't see their faces, but I just thought it was thanks.
我很嫉妒，我的履历里居然没有任何戏剧历史。你在戏剧方面会很棒，老兄。我记得二十出头时在纽约试镜过几次，在台上面对剧场深处的那三个剪影进行试镜时紧张得要命，虽然你看不到他们的脸，但我当时只觉得那是“谢谢”。
Thanks, we're good. Yeah, exactly. On the darkness. to see their faces, but I just thought it was. Thanks, we're good. Yeah, exactly. On the darkness. Yeah, I just felt like I just did not belong here. The voice of Satan. And that they're doing me some kind of a favor and get your sitcom ass off the stage.
谢谢，我们好了。对，没错。在黑暗中。看不到他们的脸，但我当时只觉得那是“谢谢”。谢谢，我们好了。对，没错。在黑暗中。对，我当时就觉得我不属于这里。撒旦之声。而且他们是在帮我什么忙，赶紧把你那情景喜剧演员的屁股滚下台去。
We need to cast some real actors here. By the way, I've been thinking of this, this is Abrabo of Nothing. I'm sorry to hijack it here, but I've been thinking about this character. I was watching TV the other day in the trailer and I saw been thinking of this, this is upper bow of nothing. I'm sorry to hijack it here, but I've been thinking about this character. I was watching TV the other day in the trailer and I saw like one of those judge shows. They have like so many different judge shows, you know,
我们需要在这里选拔一些真正的演员。顺便说一句，我一直在想这个，这是绝对的无稽之谈。很抱歉在这里打断一下，但我一直在想这个角色。我前几天在拖车里看电视，我看到一直在想这个，这是绝对的无稽之谈。很抱歉在这里打断一下，但我一直在想这个角色。我前几天在拖车里看电视，我看到那种法庭秀。他们有那么多不同的法庭秀，你知道的，
judge this and whatever midday shows. And I thought, I want to do one called Judge Camp. And he's like a super campy judge. And he's like, you're wearing no shoes into my court? Guilty, get out of here. Sean, Sean crush, Sean love Peter's health. How good would Judge Camp be? You're wearing no shoes into my court guilty get out of here Sean Would judge can't be With that blazer out with that tone. I'm ruling for your mother
诸如此类的法官秀以及各种午间节目。我想，我想做一个叫“营地法官”的节目。他是一个超级做作的法官。他说，你没穿鞋就敢进我的法庭？有罪，滚出去。肖恩，肖恩迷恋，肖恩热爱皮特的健康。营地法官会有多棒？你没穿鞋就敢进我的法庭，有罪，滚出去。肖恩，营地法官会带着那种西装外套和那种语调吗？我判你母亲胜诉，
You owe her $300 Judge camp that is thanks for good. Thanks for good How many things have you done with Kenneth Lonergren? That's what my mom calls him. Lagerne. Lonergren. Lonergren? Lonergren? Yeah.
你欠她300美元。营地法官，这真是——谢谢，很好。谢谢，很好。你和肯尼斯·罗纳根合作过多少次？我妈就是这么叫他的。罗杰恩。罗纳根。罗纳根？罗纳根？对。
What did I say? Lonergren? Yeah, but everyone does it. It's amazing. What is it again? Sorry, Lon? Lon Ergen. Lon Ergen.
我刚才说什么来着？罗纳根？对，但每个人都这么叫。太神奇了。到底怎么读来着？抱歉，罗？罗纳根。罗纳根。
Lon Ergen. How many, you've done two films, at least one. I've done two films with him. Two films and how many plays? I've only done one play with him. Oh yeah? I directed a version of this as our youth. I directed a version of You Can Count on Me. God damn it, I love that movie. A one a version of You Can Count on Me.
罗纳根。多少次，你拍过两部电影，至少一部。我拍过两部他的电影。两部电影和多少部戏剧？我只演过一部戏剧。哦，是吗？我导演过一个版本的《这是我们这一代》。我导演过一个版本的《你要讲信用》。操，我爱死那部电影了。一个版本的《你要讲信用》。
God damn it, I love that. A one act version of You Can Count on Me. Really? And I acted in a one act version of You Can Count on Me. We were like on stage? Yeah, yeah. It was part of that one act festival that Missy and I did with Rob Marrow playing my character
操，我爱死那部电影了。一个单幕版的《你要讲信用》。真的吗？我还演过一个单幕版的《你要讲信用》。我们当时在舞台上吗？对，对。那是米西和我一起做的那个单幕剧节的一部分，由罗伯·莫罗饰演我在
in You Can Count on Me. For my sister, tell my sister who Missy is. with Rob Morrow playing my character in Yukina. For my sister, tell my sister who Missy is. Oh, Missy Yeager is just the most brilliant actor. She's a writer now. Daughter of Steve Yeager and granddaughter of Chuck Yeager. Not true. But really good. Thank you.
《你要讲信用》里的角色。为了我妹妹，告诉大家我妹妹是谁。由罗伯·莫罗饰演我在《你要讲信用》里的角色。为了我妹妹，告诉大家我妹妹是谁。哦，米西·耶格尔简直是最才华横溢的演员。她现在是一名作家。史蒂夫·耶格尔的女儿，查克·耶格尔的孙女。不是真的。但真的很棒。谢谢。
That covers the Yeagers, I know. Good calling, Peter. Yeah, associated with other Yeagers you've heard of. It's really from the Yeager Meister dynasty that Missy comes from. Talk to us about how exhausting it was trying to prop up that talentless actress, Laura Linney, and you can count on me. Oh, such a good movie. She asked one of these days,
我知道，这就涵盖了耶格尔家族。说得好，皮特。对，和你们听过的其他耶格尔家族有关。米西其实出身于耶格尔ermeister（野格）王朝。跟我们聊聊，在《你要讲信用》里试图支撑那个毫无才华的女演员劳拉·琳妮，到底有多累？哦，太棒的一部电影了。她总有一天，
she's gonna find some talent. Yeah, it's just, it'll wear you out, you know? Oh, just love her so much. Love her so much, the most brilliant, sweetest, most humble genius. And you could tell because you two are so high quality and just being people that that was like this extra special rocket fuel in that movie,
她会发现一些天赋的。对，这真是太消耗精力了，你知道吗？哦，太爱她了。太爱她了，最才华横溢、最甜美、最谦逊的天才。而且你能看出来，因为你们两个都极有水准，作为人也是如此，那部电影里就像有一种特别的火箭燃料，
in a movie that the chemistry and the brother-sister connection had to be sort of palpable, tangible, like, I imagine it wasn't luck that they put you two together in that you're both so kind and such a match that you could just kind of feel it through the screen, that extra little bit that gave that movie its punch. Yeah, thank you.
在一部电影中，这种化学反应和兄妹情谊必须是显而易见的、触手可及的，我想把你们两个凑在一起绝不是靠运气，因为你们都如此善良，如此契合，以至于你能通过银幕感受到那种为电影增添力量的额外火花。对，谢谢。
I was not supposed to be in that movie at all. I had to literally beg Kenny Lonergan to give me an audition for it. Really? No way. Yes. We were actually, we had lunch, we had the great success of, this is our youth. We were having lunch one day at Cafe Lou,
我本来根本不应该参演那部电影。我不得不 literalmente 求肯尼斯·罗纳根给我一次试镜机会。真的吗？不会吧。是的。其实当时我们，我们刚享受了《这是我们这一代》的巨大成功。有一天我们在13街的卢咖啡馆吃午饭，
about 13th, and we were walking out and Ethan Hawke was sitting at the bar. And Kenny's like, hey, hey Ethan, did you mean that script? And Ethan was like, oh no man, I did, it's just not for me. I just did this other thing that's basically the same character, so it's good bro, but it's not for me right now. And we started to walk out and I was like, what script?
我们正往外走，伊桑·霍克正坐在吧台边。肯尼说：“嘿，嘿，伊桑，你看了那个剧本吗？”伊桑回答：“哦，不，老兄，我看了，只是不适合我。我刚刚拍了另一个基本是同个角色的东西，所以挺好的，老兄，但现在真不适合我。”然后我们开始往外走，我问：“什么剧本？”
Yeah. Yeah. And he was like, you never run it? And I was like, no. I'm a director movie. And I was like, can I read it? He says, just don't get your fucking manager on me. I love that.
对。对。他说：“你还没看吗？”我说：“没有。”我是个导演电影的人。我说：“我能读读吗？”他说：“只要别让你他妈的经纪人来烦我就行。”我太喜欢这个了。
And finally he acquiesced and it was basically like, fine. We're gonna fucking, I'm casting Timothy Olyphant this weekend. You don't look anything like Laura or Linney. But I'm gonna give you, I'll let you audition just because you're such a pain in the ass. And, and he, he let, he brought me in on a Sunday in the casting direct, into the casting office
最后他答应了，基本上就是，“好吧。我们他妈的，我这周末就要选蒂莫西·奥利芬特了。你长得一点都不像劳拉·琳妮。但我会给你，我会让你试镜，只因为你太烦人了。”然后，他，他让我周日在选秀导演的办公室里，
with him holding a camera in one hand and reading the script in the casting direct into the casting office with him holding a camera in one hand and Reading the script in the other. Oh my god, and That was my audition after the first scene. He's like It was really good Damn it might be good in this part All right, let's read the next one And you read the next one. And you read the next one. No way. That's crazy.
和他一起，他一只手拿着摄像机，另一只手读着剧本。在选秀导演的办公室里，和他一起，他一只手拿着摄像机，另一只手读着剧本。哦，天哪，那就是我的试镜。第一场戏演完后，他说：“演得真好。操，你在这个角色里可能真的很不错。好吧，我们读下一场吧。”然后你读了下一场。然后你读了下一场。不会吧。太疯狂了。
It was like, you're really fucking goodness. That's great. Great. Just great. That's hysterical. And we will be right back. We get support from Car Shield. Traveling by car is practically a way of life, but the last thing you want to do is get stuck on the side of the road.
感觉就像，“你他妈真的很棒。”太棒了。太棒了。简直太滑稽了。我们马上回来。我们得到了CarShield的支持。开车出行几乎是一种生活方式，但你最不想遇到的就是抛锚在路边。
If you're one of millions of Americans driving an out-of-warranty vehicle, you're liable to be on the hook for thousands of dollars in costly repairs, even if your car is only three years old. With protection plans starting at around $100 a month, CarShield offers varying levels of coverage and most plans include coast-to-coast roadside assistance, courtesy towing, and car rental options at no extra cost. CarShield offers repair coverage for up to 5,000 parts,
如果你是数百万驾驶过保修期车辆的美国人之一，你很可能会背上数千美元的高昂维修费用，即使你的车才三年新。CarShield的保障计划起价约为每月100美元，提供不同级别的保障，大多数计划包括全国范围的道路救援、免费拖车和租车选项，无需额外费用。CarShield提供高达5000个零部件的维修保障，
more parts than ever before. And here's the beauty, no dealing with paperwork or headaches, you pick the mechanic and CarShield takes care of the rest. Plus, they've got this sweet price lock guarantee and your rate stays put no matter how many claims you file. This year, avoid the hassle of costly car repairs with CarShield.
零部件比以往任何时候都多。美妙之处在于，无需处理繁琐的 paperwork 或头疼的事情，你选择修理厂，CarShield负责剩下的。此外，他们还有超棒的保价承诺，无论你理赔多少次，你的费率保持不变。今年，让CarShield帮你免去高昂汽车维修的烦恼。
Visit our URL at carshield.com slash smartlass and save 20% today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartlass to save 20%. Visit carshield.com slash smartlass to lock in your price today. Smartlass is brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. As the new year kicks off, business owners and hiring managers are on the hunt for top talent, which is no easy task. If you're currently hiring, you can probably relate. It's challenging to find qualified candidates.
访问我们的网址 carshield.com slash smartlass，今天即可节省20%。再重复一遍，那是 carshield.com slash smartlass，可节省20%。访问 carshield.com slash smartlass，今天就锁定你的价格。SmartLess 部分内容由 ZipRecruiter 赞助。新年伊始，企业主和招聘经理都在寻找顶尖人才，这绝非易事。如果你正在招聘，你可能会感同身受。找到合格的候选人极具挑战性。
That's why you need ZipRecruiter. ZipRecruiter's powerful matching technology finds the right people for your roles fast. And right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. Discover why ZipRecruiter is so effective. As soon as you post your job, ZipRecruiter Smart Technology starts showing you candidates whose skill and experience match it. Top candidates are encouraged to respond to your job post and even lets you send them a personal invite to apply.
这就是你需要 ZipRecruiter 的原因。ZipRecruiter 强大的匹配技术能快速为你找到合适的人选。现在，你可以免费试用 ziprecruiter.com slash smartless。发现 ZipRecruiter 为何如此高效。一旦你发布职位，ZipRecruiter 的智能技术就会开始向你展示技能和经验相匹配的候选人。我们会鼓励优秀候选人回复你的职位发布，甚至允许你向他们发送个性化邀请来申请。
As you rate candidates, ZipRecruiter will send you more of the ones you like. I wonder if I can just put up like podcast hosts because I might be looking for two other podcast hosts to join me. I don't want to get ahead of myself or over my skis too much, but I think you know where I'm going with this. But I am going to go to Zipper Critter because if I put out what I'm looking for, I'm going to get matches the very same day. This is really great. I love that. Okay. This is great. I love Zipper Critter. This month, find the talent you need
当你对候选人进行评分时，ZipRecruiter 会向你推荐更多你喜欢的候选人。我在想，我是不是可以发布像播客主持人这样的职位，因为我可能在寻找其他两位播客主持人加入我。我不想操之过急或过于自大，但我认为你知道我要说什么。但我还是要用 ZipRecruiter，因为如果我发布我的需求，当天就能得到匹配的人选。这真的太棒了。我太喜欢了。好的。这太棒了。我喜欢 ZipRecruiter。这个月，用 ZipRecruiter 寻找你所需的人才，
to fill all your roles with Zip Recruiter. See for yourself why four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to our exclusive web address right now to try Zip Recruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash Smartless. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash SMA-RTL-ESS.
填补你所有的职位空缺。亲自体验为什么五分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。立即访问我们的专属网址，免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless。再重复一遍，那是 ZipRecruiter.com slash Smartless。再重复一遍，那是 ziprecruiter.com slash SMA-RTL-ESS。
ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. Smartless is sponsored by Nutrifull. This year, change how you see your hair with Nutrifull. This daily hair growth supplement helps improve hair strength, length, and visible thickness. Everyone's root causes of hair thinning are different, so a one-size-fits-all approach to hair growth doesn't cut it. NutriFall has multiple formulas that are tailored to give your hair what it needs to grow throughout different stages of your life.
ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。SmartLess 由 Nutrafull 赞助。今年，用 Nutrafull 改变你对头发的看法。这款日常生发补充剂有助于改善头发强度、长度和可见厚度。每个人头发变稀疏的根本原因各不相同，因此千篇一律的生发方法是行不通的。Nutrafull 拥有多种配方，旨在为你的头发提供在人生不同阶段生长所需营养。
With NutriFall, building a hair growth routine this year is simple. Purchase online no prescription required. With free shipping and automated deliveries, you'll never miss a day. Take the first step towards healthy hair this year. For a limited time, Neutrofall is offering our listeners $10 off your first month subscription and free shipping when you go to Neutrophal.com and enter the promo code SMARTLESS. Find out why over 4500 healthcare professionals and hairstylists recommend Neutrophal for healthier hair. Neutrophal.com, spelled N-U-T-R-A-F-O-L.
有了 Nutrafull，今年建立生发日常变得很简单。在线购买，无需处方。通过免费配送和自动配送，你绝不会错过任何一天。今年迈出拥有健康秀发的第一步。限时优惠，访问 Neutrophal.com 并输入促销代码 SMARTLESS，Nutrophal 即为我们的听众提供首月订阅减免10美元及免运费优惠。了解为什么超过4500名医疗专业人员和发型师推荐 Nutrophal 以获得更健康的头发。Neutrophal.com，拼写为 N-U-T-R-A-F-O-L。
Com promo code SMARTLESS. That's Neutrophal.com, promo code smartless. And now back to the show. Mark, there's two things I'm obsessed with, theater stories, if you got one, and medical stories. And so, but you don't have to do either one and you can set, you can not answer any question you don't want to.
Com 促销代码 SMARTLESS。那是 Neutrophal.com，促销代码 smartless。现在回到节目中。马克，我有两件事极其痴迷，一个是戏剧故事，如果你有的话，另一个是医疗故事。所以，但你大可不必讲这两者中的任何一个，你可以拒绝回答任何你不想回答的问题。
But the, what happened to you during You Can Count on Me is fascinating to me, medically. Actually, that was after, after all that. Okay. And I was, you know, I was on my way, you know, I was like all that big agents and everything. And, yeah, I had a brain tumor after like the success of You Can Count on Me.
但是，你在拍《你要讲信用》期间发生在你身上的事情，从医学角度来看让我觉得很着迷。其实那是之后，在那之后发生的。好吧。而且我当时，你知道的，我正在上升期，你知道的，我当时签约了大经纪公司之类的一切。然后，是的，就在《你要讲信用》成功后，我得了脑瘤。
And you had a dream about it or something? Yeah. Wow. It was crazy. Yeah, it's the craziest thing. I was actually shooting the last castle with Gandolfini and Robert Redford and I had about a week left on that. My my son sunrise was like nine and a half months pregnant and the baby was eminently
你还做了一个关于它的梦什么的？对。哇。太疯狂了。对，最疯狂的事情。我当时其实正在和加多芬尼以及罗伯特·雷德福一起拍《最后的城堡》，我在那部电影里大概还剩一周的戏份。我的，我太太桑妮怀孕已经九个半月了，宝宝即将
coming and I had you know I had one of those like 4 AM calls and I woke up probably around three and I just had this crazy dream and it wasn't like any other dream I'd ever had. It was just like you have a brain tumor. It wasn't even a voice, it was just pure knowledge. You have a brain tumor. That's insane. And you have to deal with it immediately.
出生，而且你知道的，我接到了那种凌晨4点出工的电话，我大概3点左右醒来，我做了个极其疯狂的梦，那跟我以往做过的任何梦都不同。感觉就像是“你得了脑瘤”。甚至都不是一个声音，而是一种纯粹的认知。你得了脑瘤。太疯狂了。而且你必须立刻处理它。
That's crazy, Jesus. Wait. I mean, were there any symptoms deal with it immediately. That's crazy. Jesus. Wait. I mean, were there any symptoms? No, no, it's funny. I had like an ear infection that night and so I was feeling, you know, that was hurting me and so I went to the cast doctor the next day who was literally sat on the board of, you know,
太疯狂了，天哪。等等。我是说，当时有什么症状吗？需要立刻处理。太疯狂了，天哪。等等。我是说，当时有什么症状吗？没有，没有，很有意思。那天晚上我得了中耳炎，所以我感觉，你知道的，那让我很不舒服，所以我第二天就去找了剧组医生，她甚至在……的董事会里任职，
the Nashville Presbyterian Hospital. And I said, listen, this is gonna sound crazy. I ended this dream last night, brain tumor. Fucking actors. She said, that is crazy. But there's no reason that you should, you know, have to worry about it. I'll order you a CAT scan
田纳西长老会医院。我说：“听着，这听起来可能很疯狂。我昨晚做了个梦，脑瘤。”真他妈演员思维。她说：“这太疯狂了。但你没有任何理由需要为此担心。我给你开个CT扫描，
and we'll go right after work today. And we'll show how crazy you are. And I was like, oh, great, I am crazy. Just do it anyway. And I went and then we went up to the neurologist's office who's gonna read the scan and the nurse calls the doctor out. I could hear them talking in the other room.
我们今天下班就去。好证明你有多疯狂。”我说：“哦，太棒了，我确实疯了。不管怎样，先做了再说吧。”然后我去了，接着我们去了神经科医生的办公室，看扫描结果的医生，护士把医生叫了出去。我能听到他们在隔壁房间说话。
She comes in, she's just kind of like a zombie. And she says, you have a mask behind your left ear the size of a golf ball. says you have a mass behind your left ear the size of a golf ball. I agree. And yeah, we don't know what it is. We can't tell until it's biopsied. Same ear as the earache, the ear infection.
她走进来，整个人就像个行尸走肉。她说：“你左耳后面有一个高尔夫球大小的肿块。”说你左耳后面有一个高尔夫球大小的肿块。我同意。对，我们不知道那是什么。在做活检之前无法确定。跟耳痛、耳部感染是同一侧。
Yeah, same ear as the earache. And I said, yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Oh, wow. It's been such an anxiety. How old were you? Yeah, I was 33. 33, and thank God I was benign.
对，跟耳痛是同一侧。我说：“对，对。哦，对。哦，哇。”一直这么焦虑。你当时多大？对，我33岁。33岁，谢天谢地是良性的。
About to have a baby. About to have a baby. And you just finished, you can count on me. And you've worked super hard and you've just done all this stuff. And now you're making a movie with Robert Redford and Gandalfini. it's all coming together. And in this moment you're like, uh-huh.
正要迎来一个宝宝。正要迎来一个宝宝。你刚拍完《你要讲信用》。你工作极其努力，刚刚做完了所有这些事情。现在你正和罗伯特·雷德福以及加多芬尼拍电影。一切都在走向正轨。而在这个时刻，你心想：“呃——哦。”
Uh-huh. And they're like, it's on. So then I didn't tell Sonny, because she had the birth plan, she did the yoga, she had the doula, we had the hot tub ordered, we had like. For the party after. This is like her wedding, you know man? Like like, for the party after. This is like, yeah. This is like her wedding, you know, man.
呃——哦。他们说：“开始了。”所以当时我没有告诉桑妮，因为她有生育计划，她练习瑜伽，她请了导乐，我们订购了浴缸，我们有……为了之后的派对。这就像她的婚礼一样，你知道吗？就像，为了之后的派对。这就像她的婚礼一样，你知道吗？
Like this is like her christening, her kinsignero. Yeah. And I just was like, I can't, you know, she's already like, oh God, him again. I mean, is everything gotta be about him? Yeah. Yeah. And so I just couldn't.
这就好像是她的洗礼，她的成人礼。对。我当时就想，我不能，你知道的，她肯定会觉得“哦，天哪，又来这套。难道所有事都得围着他转吗？”对。对。所以我实在说不出口。
And like a few days, like a week after the baby, I had to go in and meet the neurologist and decide what I was gonna do. And had you told Sonny yet? I hadn't told her. Wow. What a thing to sit on. Until the night before.
就在几天后，也就是宝宝出生大约一周后，我不得不去见神经科医生，决定我该怎么做。你当时告诉桑妮了吗？我还没告诉她。哇。这可真够难熬的。直到前一天晚上。
Dude, I mean, yeah, like Jason says, like you're sitting there with all this stuff going on. What a thing to sit on. What a thing to sit on. What a thing to have literally in your head and also swimming around in your head in both ways. I mean, and that time between you know and telling her must have been just absolute torture. It was like shave your head and cut into your scalp
老兄，我是说，对，正如杰森所说，你坐在那里，身边发生了那么多事。这可真够难熬的。这可真够难熬的。脑子里简直装满了各种事情，思绪万千。我是说，从你知道病情到告诉她的那段时间，简直绝对是一种折磨。就像是剃光你的头发，切开你的头皮，
and take the thing out. Oh yeah. I mean, it was a full, I have a big scar, you know that quarter horseshoe thing What did they say that the prognosis was like were you super concerned or were they like listen? This is something we do a lot It's it's early blah blah blah. I was super concerned because I didn't you know, I hadn't really gotten that I hadn't met with a Neurologist, you know, they're I What I was told by the doctors was like, it's a brain tumor, but from the dream, the dream was so intense,
然后把那东西取出来。哦，对。我是说，那是一个完整的，我有一个很大的伤疤，你知道那个四分之一马蹄形的伤痕吗？医生说预后怎么样？你当时超级担心，还是他们说：“听着，这是我们经常做的手术，发现得很早，等等？”我当时超级担心，因为我没有，你知道的，我当时还没跟神经科医生碰过面，你知道，他们……医生跟我说的是：“这是一个脑瘤，”但从那个梦开始，那个梦太强烈了，
and it was literally like, you have a brain tumor, you have to deal with it immediately. Right. And it just had the sense of doom. And I'm like, it's a fucking brain tumor. You're like, no, that's just a tumor talking You know how my my tumor ran away with me But I love that it was close enough to your ear to actually speak to you and say hey
字面意思就是“你得了脑瘤，你必须立刻处理。”没错。那种末日降临的感觉太强烈了。我心想：“这他妈是个脑瘤。”你会想，“不，那只是肿瘤在说话。”你知道我的肿瘤是怎么让我胡思乱想的吗？但我喜欢的是，它离你的耳朵足够近，甚至能直接对你说话，说：“嘿，
That's crazy that you had a dream about it. Oh, dude. So they take you in there, they shave a spot, they cut open your scalp, they cut it out, and then like, is there an extensive rehab process or are you out and about that afternoon? No, man. Well, first of all, I just gotta say, when I told Sunny about it, first she thought I was joking. And then she just burst into tears and said,
你居然梦到这个，太疯狂了。哦，老兄。所以他们把你带进去，剃掉一块头发，切开你的头皮，把它切除，然后呢？会有漫长的康复过程，还是那天下午就能到处溜达了？不，老兄。首先，我必须得说，当我把这事告诉桑妮时，她首先以为我在开玩笑。然后她突然失声痛哭，说——
I always knew you were gonna die young. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. That's horrible.
我一直都知道你会英年早逝。天哪。天哪。天哪。天哪。天哪。天哪。太可怕了。
That's horrible. But so good. That's really good. If you wrote it in the script, it would be too much. Uh-huh. That's so good. Let's just play that instead of saying it. Here we go, everybody.
太可怕了。但又妙极了。真的太棒了。如果你把它写进剧本里，那就过头了。嗯哼。太棒了。我们就直接演这段，别说出来了。来吧，各位。
Exactly. It's so good. Oh my God. Well. Wow. I think I might have left. So they took it out. It was benign, but it left you a little deaf in your ear.
没错。太棒了。天哪。好吧。哇。我想我可能已经离开了。所以他们把它切掉了。那是良性的，但让你的耳朵有点耳聋。
Not a little, just totally. Really? Completely deaf in one ear? Completely deaf in one ear. When I woke up, the left side of my face was totally paralyzed. No. Like, I couldn't even close my eye and was talking on the side of my mouth like this, you know?
不只是一点，而是完全聋了。真的吗？一只耳朵完全聋了？一只耳朵完全聋了。当我醒来时，我左半边脸完全瘫痪了。不会吧。我甚至都闭不上眼睛，说话时嘴巴只能歪向一边，你知道吗？
Did they say to expect this or was that a shock to you? They said to me, I had like a 20% chance of nicking my nerve on the left side of my face and killing it. And then I had 70% chance of losing my hearing, which went and at that point, like you and the airplane, you're like, yeah, you're crazy. I don't really believe in you,
他们提前说过会有这种情况，还是对你来说是个打击？他们对我说，我左脸神经被切断并坏死的几率大概有20%。然后我有70%的几率失去听力和视力，到了那个时候，就像你和那架飞机一样，你会觉得，好吧，你疯了。我其实不相信你，
but take my hearing, but let me keep the face and just let me be the father. Yeah, Foxhole prayers, right? I mean, like that, yeah. Reverse for me, they took my face, but I can hear great. You're beautiful. And you have incredible hearing, by the way. Thank you, thank you so much. You're welcome incredible hearing, by the way. Thank you, guys.
但拿走我的听力吧，让我保住这张脸，让我继续当父亲。对吧，战壕里的祈祷，对吧？我是说，就像那样，对吧。反过来对我而言，他们拿走了我的脸，但我听力极佳。你很美。顺便说一句，你的听力好得惊人。谢谢，非常感谢。不客气，顺便说一句，听力好得惊人。谢谢你们。
Thank you so much. You're welcome. Mark, can we start at the beginning? And I wanna know more about you. You grew up in Wisconsin. When did you move to LA? What made you move? Did the whole family move to LA?
非常感谢。不客气。马克，我们能从头开始吗？我想多了解你一些。你在威斯康星州长大。你是什么时候搬到洛杉矶的？是什么促使你搬家的？全家人都搬到洛杉矶了吗？
Yeah. And why? We moved, no, no, the whole family didn't move to LA. We started in Wisconsin. You know, the family business sort move to LA. We started in Wisconsin. The family business sort of blew up. My family business was they had a construction painting business. Construction painting?
是的。为什么？我们搬了，不，不，全家人没有搬到洛杉矶。我们从威斯康星州开始。你知道的，家族生意差不多搬到了洛杉矶。我们从威斯康星州起步。家族生意差不多黄了。我家族的生意是建筑油漆生意。建筑油漆？
Yeah, like huge jobs, like the Libby factory and our GM motors, American motors, but sandblasting and- Paint the whole factory. Huge, huge jobs. Okay. And that went under and my dad was, you know, trying to start a new life.
对，就像巨大的工程，比如利比工厂和通用汽车、美国汽车公司，还有喷砂以及——粉刷整座工厂。巨大无比的工程。好吧。后来那家公司倒闭了，我父亲就，你知道的，试图开始新的生活。
And so that took us to San Diego. And he had the original soda butler, which was you can make your own soda at home for fractions of the cost. You carbonate your own soda. Yeah, I remember that. That was his baby. And he was ready to take off, like we see it today.
所以这让我们去了圣地亚哥。他拥有最早的苏打管家（soda butler），也就是你可以在家以极低的成本自己制作苏打水。你自己给苏打水打气。对，我记得那个。那是他的心头肉。他当时准备大干一场，就像我们今天看到的那样。
And Coca-Cola and Pepsi and all those brands stopped selling, wouldn't sell him the syrup because it was a home delivery kind of system and There's an anti-trust law against that they have to sell those syrups to the public really and he was and they he's like this is against the law and they're like fuck you take us to court and Basically once those those high-end brands weren't available to people, they just sort of lost its popularity
结果可口可乐、百事可乐以及所有那些品牌停止供货，不肯把糖浆卖给他，因为这是一种送货上门的服务系统，而且有反垄断法规定他们必须向公众出售这些糖浆，真的，然后他就在那说，这违反了法律，而他们却说，去你的，有本事告我们去。基本上，一旦那些高端品牌不再对大众开放，它就有点失去人气了
and that crapped up. But so we were living in San Diego. With nothing to do. Yeah. And we moved there the day after I graduated from high school. Wow. And I had no support group there.
然后事情就搞砸了。但当时我们住在圣地亚哥。无所事事。是的。我们在我高中毕业的第二天搬到了那里。哇。我在那里没有任何支持系统。
And I was at the base. I mean, I'd been surfing since I started living support group there. And I was just based, I mean, I'd been surfing since I started living in Virginia Beach. So all I was doing was really surfing and smoking weed. You know, we all know that. Sure. And wrestling, by the way, you were a wrestler. Yeah, I was a wrestler during high school.
我就在基地。我是说，自从我住在弗吉尼亚海滩以来我就一直在冲浪。所以支持系统就在那里。我当时就是在基地，我是说，自从我住在弗吉尼亚海滩以来我就一直在冲浪。所以我所做的事基本上就是冲浪和抽大麻。你知道的，我们都知道这一点。当然。顺便说一句，还有摔跤，你以前是个摔跤手。对，我高中时是个摔跤手。
It's crazy. It's gonna get us to Foxcatcher at some point in this review. If you ever shut up. I love that movie. I love that movie. And someone said, go to Los Angeles. You want to be an actor, go to Los Angeles, go to the Stella Adler Conservatory,
太疯狂了。在这次回顾的某个时刻，这肯定会把我们引向《狐狸捕手》。如果你能闭嘴的话。我喜欢那部电影。我喜欢那部电影。然后有人说，去洛杉矶吧。你想当演员，就去洛杉矶，去斯特拉·阿德勒表演艺术学院，
you'll meet people there, I'll take care of you. Where did the acting interest come from? In Wisconsin, was it born? Yeah, man. My family's Catholic, my grandmother was a born-again Christian and my father was a Baha'i. So I had like the whole Middle East, a good part of the Middle East living in my home.
你在那里会结识一些人，我会照顾你的。你对表演的兴趣是从哪里来的？在威斯康星州，它萌芽了吗？是的，老兄。我的家庭信奉天主教，我祖母是生发基督徒，我父亲是巴哈伊信徒。所以我家里就像住着整个中东，中东很大一部分。
Yeah. And they still couldn't get along. home, you know, and they still couldn't get along. First of all, I'd go to church and I was like, wow, that guy is, wow, he's captivating. He's captivating as the priest could be. Then I was saved by Jimmy Swagger at the First Assembly of God and I was like, whoa, he's got a band. He's sweating, he's like Elvis.
是的。而且他们仍然合不来。家，你知道的，而且他们仍然合不来。首先，我去教堂时我想，哇，那个人，哇，他太迷人了。他简直就像神父一样迷人。后来我被吉米·斯瓦格在第一神召会拯救了，我想，哇，他有个乐队。他在出汗，他就像猫王一样。
So I, you know, I started, I got an idea what it was like to perform and it was weird, my grandmother one night, I was probably like eight, she, everything that happened to me, that's like core experiences were my grandmother, whether it was my first enema or it was... And my last, by the way.
所以，我（你知道的），我开始对表演是什么有了个概念，这很诡异，有一天晚上我祖母——我当时大概八岁——她，发生在我身上的所有事，就像核心经历一样都跟我祖母有关，不管是我的第一次灌肠还是……顺便说一句，也是我的最后一次。
I was just gonna say not your last, yeah. And being saved by Jimmy Swagger, but also letting me stay up at night and watch the movie of the week. And that one was Streetcar Named Desire. Oh wow. And I saw Brando like at eight years old and I was like, I didn't know it was Brando.
我正想说不是你的最后一次呢，对。还有被吉米·斯瓦格拯救，同时也让我熬夜看周播电影。那部电影就是《欲望号街车》。哦，哇。我在八岁时就看到了白兰度，当时我想，我不知道那是白兰度。
I don't even know, you know, I was like, grandma, who is that? She said, it tells me. I was like, what is he doing? She says, he's acting. I was like, I want to do that. She's like, let's get finished with this anime first. And then we'll.
我甚至都不知道（你知道的），我当时说：奶奶，那是谁？她说，它告诉我。我当时想：他在干什么？她说：他在演戏。我想：我也想那样。她说：先做完这个灌肠再说。然后我们再……
Let's clean you out first. I have just the thing for you. We're going to cure you of that. Wow. Wow. So then that kind of goes on pause through moving. Yeah. And then you're out.
先把你清理干净再说。我正好有适合你的东西。我们要把你的这个毛病治好。哇。哇。所以后来因为搬家，这事就暂停了。对。然后你离开了。
Then you move up from San Diego to LA to pursue that? Yeah, so I'm like, dad, I kind of want to go to the school. And he said, I was like, but it's in LA. And I've never really been away from home. I was 18 and he's like, well, you know, why not? I was like, I don't know. I'm afraid.
然后你从圣地亚哥搬到洛杉矶去追求这个？对，所以我就说：爸，我有点想去那个学校。他说，我说：但它在洛杉矶。我从来没有真正离开过家。我当时18岁，他说：嗯，你知道的，为什么不呢？我说：我不知道。我很害怕。
And he's like, well, what's the worst that can happen? What are you afraid? I was like, I don't know. I'm afraid. And he's like, well, what's the worst that can happen? What are you afraid? I was like, what if I die? And he's like, well, if you die, who gives a shit? You know, he won't even know. Yeah. I mean, I'll be sad, but I mean, you're not gonna know. I like your dad.
他说：嗯，最坏的结果会怎样？你在害怕什么？我说：我不知道。我很害怕。他说：嗯，最坏的结果会怎样？你在害怕什么？我说：如果我死了呢？他说：嗯，如果你死了，谁他妈在乎？你知道的，你甚至都不会知道。对。我是说，我会难过的，但我是说，你不会知道的。我喜欢你爸。
And so I did. I did too. And I went up there and I was taking the train. I used to, we didn't have any money at that point. We were just poor as church mice. So I'd bus tables at night and then the next day, I went to school every other day. So I'd work one day and make just enough money
然后我就去了。我也很喜欢。我上去了，我坐的是火车。我过去，我们当时根本没钱。我们穷得像教堂里的小老鼠。所以我晚上去餐厅端盘子，然后第二天，我每隔一天去一次学校。所以我工作一天，赚到的钱刚好够
to pay for a round trip train ticket and buy a burrito that I cut in the thirds. A cheese burrito right off of Hollywood Boulevard at Dos Burritos. Yeah, that's and um and yeah Wow, and that was it and I and I just had my mind blown and I'm like this is what I'm gonna do for the rest of my life And then and then from that acting school was there like a showcase in there where agents came by and you got an agent And then you started getting some auditions and got a couple jobs and just sort of a natural progression. I was there for seven years. Without representation.
买一张往价火车票，再买一个被我切成三截的墨西哥卷饼。一个奶酪卷饼，就在好莱坞大道旁边的“两只卷饼”店。对，就是那样，然后，还有，哇，就是这样，然后我整个人被震撼了，我想：这就是我这辈子要干的事。然后，然后从那个表演学校出来后，那里有什么试镜会吗，经纪人会来，然后你找了个经纪人，然后你开始得到一些试镜机会，接了几个工作，就这样顺理成章地发展下来了。我在那呆了七年。没有经纪人。
Pony my craft. And bartending at the Chateau Marmont, right? But didn't you drive a motor, you rode a motorcycle everywhere, which is my first thing was when I read you, you had a motorcycle and you drove to auditions. I was like, what about your hair? Like, it was amazing.
打磨我的手艺。还在地堡酒店当过酒保，对吧？但你不是开着一辆摩托车吗，你到处都骑摩托车，我读到关于你的第一件事就是，你有一辆摩托车，你骑着它去试镜。我当时想：你的头发怎么办？天哪，太惊人了。
Cause there was no helmets back then, which is also deadly. Oh, my hair was awesome. It was all wind blown. You know, it looked like it crossed between Salminio and, yeah, and Bozo. Bozo. Yeah, no, I wild that you drove a motorcycle everywhere.
因为那时没有头盔，这也是致命的。哦，我的头发帅呆了。全都被风吹乱了。你知道的，看起来介于萨尔·米内奥和……对，还有波佐之间。波佐。对，不，你到处骑摩托车，这太疯狂了。
Like I can't imagine. I couldn't afford a car. It was like I had a $250, 1974 Honda XR250 that I could personally work on when it broke down. And that was the only way I could get around LA. I just couldn't afford, I was living in a closet for 200 bucks. My whole nut was about 300 bucks a month.
就像我无法想象。我买不起汽车。我有一辆250美元的1974年本田XR250摩托车，坏了的时候我自己就能修。那是我在洛杉矶四处奔波的唯一方式。我根本买不起，我当时住在衣帽间里，房租200块。我每月的全部花销大约是300块钱。
So was there a big job that kinda launched you, or was it sort of like a little bit here, a little bit there, and just sort of a slow progression? It was a very slow progression. I mean, there's really no reason that I should have tried as long as I did because that was from 18 to 28. I mean, that is such a long time to like stick with, you wanna talk about stick with it.
那么，有没有什么大工作开启了你的事业，或者说是一点一点慢慢积累，也就是一种缓慢的发展过程？这是一个非常缓慢的发展过程。我是说，真的没有什么理由让我坚持那么久，因为那是从18岁到28岁。我是说，坚持那么久真是太漫长了，如果你想谈论坚持的话。
There's so much opportunity in there for you to say fuck it and throw it in and go do anything else. Yeah. I did. I tried. No, but I mean, yeah. I'm just saying the similarities between your story and Sean's story. Yeah, I love that. No, I am. No, but I'm thinking about like, I think if I'm remembering correctly, you came to LA and you smoked a lot of weed and wrestled and you'd never nut for less than $300. If I'm putting all the pieces, if I'm thinking back, if I'm thinking of the right...
其中有太多的机会让你说去他妈的然后放弃，去干点别的什么。对。我试过。没有，但我是说，对。我只是在说你的故事和肖恩的故事之间的相似之处。对，我喜欢这个。不，我是。不，但我在想，如果我没记错的话，你来到洛杉矶，抽了很多大麻，摔跤，你的月花销还不到300美元。如果我把所有的碎片拼凑起来，如果我在回想，如果我想的是对的……
300 bucks for a nut? That's why Will was silent for less than two minutes. He's been constructing that show. He was just shaping that joke. We love it. It was so well executed too, Will. It was beautiful. I was like, wait, that's not my story.
花销只要300块？难怪威尔两分钟都没吭声。他一直在构思那个包袱。他刚刚在琢磨那个笑话。我们太喜欢了。而且执行得真好，威尔。太棒了。我当时想：等等，那不是我的故事。
I moved to LA and got a sitcom pretty cute. It was beautiful. I was like, wait, that's not my story. I moved to LA and got a sitcom right away. God bless you. I love you for that. But Mark, let me ask you this, so because my recollection is, so you're 28, but you, when you came to New York and started doing stuff with Naked Angels,
我搬到洛杉矶，马上就接了一部情景喜剧，挺酷的。太棒了。我当时想：等等，那不是我的故事。我搬到洛杉矶，马上就接了一部情景喜剧。上帝保佑你。为此我爱你。不过马克，我问你个问题，因为我的记忆是，所以你28岁了，但是你，当你来到纽约并开始和“裸体天使”剧团一起做事时，
with those guys with Missy and Kenny, is when I first met you when you guys were doing the short plays, Before This Is Our Youth, you guys were doing, and you had done, oh no, right before This Is Our Youth, you had done a movie and you had an, I feel like you had an agent at that point, like right before This Is Our Youth,
和那些家伙（米茜和肯尼）在一起时，正是我第一次见到你们的时候，当时你们在演那些短剧，在《这是我们的青春》之前，你们在演，而且你做过，哦不对，就在《这是我们的青春》之前，你演过一部电影，而且你有一个，我觉得你那时就有经纪人了，就在《这是我们的青春》之前，
am I right about that? Yeah, I did, yeah. I'd done a few soft core horror films. No, that's not true. Yeah, it is. For real? Mirror, Mirror 2 and Mirror, Mirror 3. The Raven Dance and The Voyeur.
我没记错吧？对，我有，是的。我演过几部软色情恐怖片。不，那不是真的。不，是的。真的吗？《镜子，镜子2》和《镜子，镜子3》。《渡鸦之舞》和《偷窥狂》。
Yeah, wow. I will be looking for that. No, there was something, what was the other movie you did? Most did like a teen movie or like you did like a like a ski movie. Am I remembering this right? No, there was I had a I had a one-day role and there goes my baby. I don't know if you remember that I don't like that sounds like a made-up name of a movie. Yeah, I know and then I you know And I actually did have a couple pilot Yeah, I know and then I you know what I actually did have a couple pilot
对，哇。我会去找来看看的。不，还有别的，你演的另一部电影是什么？大多数演的就像青少年电影，或者像你演了一部滑雪电影。我没记错吧？不，有一个，我有一个只有一天的龙套角色，在《我的宝贝要走了》里。我不知道你记不记得，我不喜欢那个，听起来像个编出来的电影名字。对，我知道，然后我（你知道的），我其实确实拍过几个试播集，对，我知道，然后我（你知道的），我其实确实拍过几个试播集
shots that never went. Oh with Ken with Kenny Marino, Ken Marino. Yeah, no shit. Yeah, that was like that was like my first job It was it was the play like the little nair do well, you know, you guys great brothers Would you guys play brothers? Yeah, did you really? Yeah, we were brothers me him and Shawn Aston No, Oh wow Yeah, killer cast love Sean love Ken marino. Yeah, all-time great dude. Yeah, yeah, we should have got that We should have you know, they they blew it someday someone will show that pilot Hey, you know I had an idea you guys could probably actualize this. Why doesn't someone start a movie state a to actualize this, why doesn't someone start a movie, a streaming station with all of the fucking
后来都没播。哦，和肯，和肯尼·马里诺，肯·马里诺。对，没开玩笑。对，那就像，那就像我的第一份工作。那是一部剧，就像那种一事无成的人，你知道的，你们几个演伟大的兄弟。你们演的是兄弟吗？对，真的吗？对，我们是兄弟，我和他还有肖恩·奥斯廷。哦，哇。对，全明星阵容，我爱肖恩，我爱肯·马里诺。对，史上最伟大的家伙。对，对，我们本该拿下那个的。我们本该（你知道的），他们搞砸了。总有一天有人会播放那个试播集。嘿，（你知道的）我有个主意，你们几个或许能把它实现。为什么有人不创办一个电影公司，去实现这个，为什么有人不创办一个电影公司、一个流媒体电台，播放所有那些我们拍过的、该死的好剧却被砍掉的试播集和电视剧呢？
failed pilots and television shows that we all did? I've asked that for a long time, and you'd think that the networks would, just like during the summers, show all the pilots that they didn't pick up, just to sort of cross monetize what they did, and the reason they don't do it is because they don't want one of those pilots to be well received and then they look like
我问过这个问题很久了，你本会觉得各大电视网会这么做，就像在夏天的时候那样，把所有他们没有挑中的试播集都播一遍，只是为了把他们做过的内容进行跨平台变现，他们不这么做的原因是因为他们不希望其中某个试播集大受欢迎，那样他们看起来就像
Schmuck for not ordering it. That's the only reason they don't do it. It's the same reason that they don't want to say that they hate putting movies and turnaround and letting other studios make the movie on the off chance that another turnaround is for Tracy is that if a studio is developing a movie and then they decide they're not gonna make it,
没订购它的笨蛋。这就是他们不这么做的唯一原因。这也是为什么他们不想承认自己讨厌把电影打回重做并让其他制片厂来拍的原因，以防另一部打回重做的电影给特蕾西拍，就是如果一个制片厂在开发一部电影，然后他们决定不拍了，
they have the potential in another studio to come in and say like, hey, we'll pay you for whatever it costs you to develop that script and we wanna make that movie. They don't like to do it because- They'd rather eat the fee on that. Well, yeah, because if it goes to another studio and it does really well, then the guy who decided not to make it gets fired, right?
他们有潜力让另一个制片厂介入并说，嘿，我们会付给你开发那个剧本所花的所有费用，我们想拍那部电影。他们不喜欢这么做是因为——宁愿自己吃下这笔费用。嗯，对，因为如果它去了另一个制片厂而且大获成功，那么那个决定不拍的家伙就会被解雇，对吧？
Right, yeah. And it happens all the fucking time. But you're right, Mark, that's a great idea. There's so many great pilots out there. There are people who do show them sometimes because what's that great one that Owen Wilson Jack did, Black, about the talking motorcycle and Owen Wilson's the voice of the,
对，没错。这种事他妈的天天都在发生。不过你说得对，马克，这是个好主意。外面有那么多优秀的试播集。有些人有时确实会播放它们，因为欧文·威尔逊和杰克拍的那部了不起的作品是什么来着，《黑衣人》，是关于一辆会说话的摩托车的，欧文·威尔逊是那个，
have you ever seen this? No, I don't. No, I want to. What were they on? It's hilarious. There's so many. That's how I met Andy and Akiva and Yorm, those guys, Lonely Island. They did a pilot, a Lonely Island pilot that Phil Lord and Chris Miller produced. That was all sketches before they got SNL. And somebody showed it to me. I was like, these guys are fucking hilarious.
你见过这个吗？不，我没有。不，我想看。它们是什么时候播的？太搞笑了。有太多了。这就是我认识安迪、阿基瓦和约姆那些人的方式，寂寞岛。他们拍过一个寂寞岛的试播集，由菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒担任制片人。那全是在他们上《周六夜现场》之前拍的小品。有人把它给我看。我当时想：这些家伙太他妈搞笑了。
And then network, you know, they didn't pick it up. And then imagine if you showed that, whoever that person is, they'd be banned from showbiz forever. Well, they're probably gone already. Yeah, that's true. I mean, they really like burned through all those executives. Yeah, it turned over fast there.
然后电视网（你知道的），他们没买。然后想象一下，如果你播了那个，不管那个人是谁，他们都会被娱乐圈永远封杀。好吧，他们可能已经不在了。嗯，确实如此。我是说，他们真的把那些高管都炒了个遍。嗯，那里的员工流动得真快。
So Mark, with those humble beginnings and an extended period of... Incredible. Was there... What about when you... It sucked. Let me just... Let's not romanticize. But was it difficult at all when you just hit the massive amount of success that you're in now, was that also a slow progression as well?
所以马克，伴随着那些卑微的起点和漫长的……难以置信。有没有……当你……这糟透了。让我直说吧……我们别把它浪漫化了。但是，当你突然迎来如今这种巨大的成功时，过程有哪怕一点点艰难吗，这也是一个缓慢的发展过程吗？
Or was there a moment where you got a big fat check or a big fat job and the transition was uncomfortable or difficult for you because of such humble, extended beginnings? All I know is my big break was a play with Holly Hunter and Carol Kane and Bill Pullman. And it was the hot thing in Los Angeles at the time. Hot LA play, you don't hear that often.
还是说有那么一个时刻，你拿到了一张巨额支票或者一份超级工作，因为你起步卑微且经历漫长，导致这种转变让你感到很不舒服或很艰难？我只知道我的重大突破是和霍利·亨特、卡罗尔·凯恩以及比尔·普尔曼一起演的一部话剧。那是当时洛杉矶最火的东西。火爆的洛杉矶话剧，这种话剧你不常听到。
No, but it was those people. And Holly'd already won the Academy Award and Carol was huge and Bill was huge. Where was the play, Amundsen? No, it was at the Met Theater. They had, they started their own theater. And yeah, it was in the early 90s. And that was gonna be my big break.
不，但那是那些人。而且霍利已经赢得了奥斯卡奖，卡罗尔名气极大，比尔名气也极大。那部话剧在哪演的，阿蒙森？不，是在大都会剧院。他们有，他们创办了自己的剧院。是的，那是在90年代初。那本来会是我的重大突破。
And I, of course, was fired four days before we opened. And, you know, a stagehand fired me because Beth Henley was the director, but she just couldn't bring herself to fire me. So they basically had a stagehand who told me he was the producer, fire me. What was your problem? Why did you get fired?
然后，我当然在开演前四天被解雇了。而且，你知道的，一个舞台监督解雇了我，因为贝丝·亨利是导演，但她就是开不了口解雇我。所以他们基本上找了一个舞台监督来告诉我他自己是制作人，然后把我解雇了。你有什么问题？你为什么被解雇？
I sucked no Why else do you get fire I bet their taste was up their ass no no, you know it honestly I was probably what what they what I was told was I I was in a different play which you know could possibly That's a director's fault. Yeah, you know director's got to get everybody in the same project. Yeah. Thank you, Jason. That's what I was trying to tell them. It's true.
我演得很烂。不然你以为为什么会被解雇？我敢打赌他们的品味有问题。不，不，你知道的，老实说，我可能，我当时被告知的是，我演的是另一部剧（你知道的），这可能……那是导演的错。是的，你知道的，导演得让每个人都在同一个频段上。谢谢你，杰森。我正想告诉他们呢。确实如此。
You know? We'll be right back. SmartLess is supported by Hydro. Hmm. Do I want to look better? Do I want to feel better? Do I want to be better? Do I want to feel better? Do I want to be overall healthier?
你知道吗？我们马上回来。SmartLess由Hydro赞助。嗯。我想看起来更好吗？我想感觉更好吗？我想变得更好吗？我想感觉更好吗？我想整体变得更健康吗？
Yeah, of course I do. We all do. We want to do whatever we can to be our best selves. But do I have the time to do it? You mean do you have 20 minutes? Yeah, you got 20 minutes to make your life better, to look better? I think you're good. Guess what? Hydro is the best. It's a state of the art at home rowing machine designed by rowers that delivers the ultimate fullbody workout. How ultimate? It works 86% of your muscles. I'm talking arms, legs, core, and it only takes 20 minutes. Rowing with hydro is low impact, so low risk of injury.
是的，我当然想。我们都想。我们想尽一切努力成为最好的自己。但我有时间这么做吗？你的意思是你有20分钟吗？是的，你有20分钟让你的生活变得更好、让自己看起来更好吗？我想你有的。你猜怎么着？Hydro是最好的。它是一台最先进的家用划船机，由划船手设计，能提供极致的全身体能锻炼。有多极致？它能锻炼你86%的肌肉。我说的是手臂、腿部、核心，而且只需20分钟。用Hydro划船是低冲击的，受伤风险很低。
The workouts are taught by Olympians and world-class athletes who are great coaches for any fitness level. Look, obviously I was saying before I was trying to shame you into like, hey, you should do this, but you should do this. The process of doing it is so easy and fun, 20 minutes. Plus, you get this great screen where you're either getting coached by all these awesome athletes who are at the top of their game, or you can just have this view of the river, which is really nice and serene while you're either getting coached by all these awesome athletes who are at the top of their game or you can just have this view of the river which is really nice and serene while you're getting your workout. There's just so many different ways to do it. Guys, it's really cool.
锻炼课程由奥运选手和世界级运动员教授，他们是适合任何健身水平的伟大教练。看，很明显我刚才说的话是想羞辱你，比如，嘿，你应该这么做，但你真的应该这么做。这样做的过程如此轻松有趣，只要20分钟。另外，你还有一个非常棒的屏幕，要么有这些处于巅峰状态的优秀运动员指导你，要么你就能欣赏到河流的美景，当你一边接受那些处于巅峰状态的优秀运动员的指导，一边欣赏真正美好而宁静的河流风光时，那种感觉真的很棒。有太多不同的方式可以做到这一点。伙计们，这真的很酷。
You're going to want to check it out because you're going to want to feel and look better. Join the growing rowing community at Hydro and make sure you let them know the smart list sent you. Head over to hydro.com and use code smart list to save up to $500 off your hydro. That's hydrow.com, code smart list to save up to $500. Hydro.com, code smart list. And now, back to the show. By the way, Mark, we could, like, there's so many, I could ask you without, like, the normal heart. We'll start with one.
你们一定会想去看看，因为你们会想让自己感觉更好、看起来更好。加入Hydro不断壮大的划船社区，一定要让他们知道是SmartLess介绍你来的。前往hydrow.com并使用代码smart less最高可节省500美元购买Hydro。网址是hydrow.com，使用代码smart less可节省高达500美元。Hydro.com，代码smart less。现在，让我们回到节目中。顺便说一句，马克，我们可以，比如，有那么多，我可以在没有那种正常心跳的情况下问你。我们从一个开始。
Just move along. Just get one. You know what I mean? I just love, I find you incredible in the normal heart. And I thought this one is you. You want a minute to think about it? No, I don't need a minute. But this much is true.
继续吧。就挑一个。你知道我的意思吗？我只是喜欢，我觉得你在《平常的心》里的表现简直不可思议。我觉得这个角色就是你。你想花一分钟考虑一下吗？不，我不需要一分钟。但这是千真万确的。
I mean, it was mind-blowing. You played those two, I mean, how did you do that? What was your approach to this much is true where you played identical twins, right? Yeah. Yeah. It's just incredible. I mean, I look at that and I was like, God, the work, like how did you even start?
我是说，这太震撼了。你扮演了那两个，我是说，你是怎么做到的？你对《我知道这是真的》这部剧的处理方法是什么，你在里面扮演了一对双胞胎，对吧？对。是的。简直不可思议。我是说，我看着那个，然后我想：天哪，这工作量，你究竟是怎么开始的？
Where do you start? Well, Derek and I, you know, I- Derek C. and France? Yeah, Derek C. and France. Director. Our director and the writer. He adapted it from the book. Genius, genius man.
你从哪里开始？我和德里克（你知道的），我——德里克·斯·弗兰斯？对，德里克·斯·弗兰斯。导演。我们的导演兼编剧。他是从书里改编的。天才，真正的大天才。
Yeah, he's a genius. I had gotten the book rights and I immediately wanted him. And, you know, he was, he'd only done his own stuff that he'd ever, and so he was taking a meeting out of courtesy because we love each other and we keep talking about working each other but we never were finding anything inside. I mean that kind.
对，他是个天才。我买下了这本书的版权，然后我马上就想要他。而且，你知道的，他，他只做过他自己的东西，从来没有，所以他出于礼貌才接见我，因为我们互相喜爱，我们一直谈论合作，但我们从来没有在里面找到任何……我是说那种。
He's like, yeah man, let's meet and we'll go for a walk and we'll talk about it. And he started with, nah, this isn't for me. I don't wanna do the CGI kind of thing with this. I don't know how to do that. And we walked for like three hours. And I just kind of pitched him what I was thinking and seeing and how it related to his work.
他说：行吧，老兄，我们见个面，去散散步，然后聊聊吧。他一开始就说：不，这不适合我。我不想在这上面搞什么CGI特效之类的东西。我不会弄那个。我们走了大约三个小时。我只是把我的想法、愿景以及它如何与他的作品联系起来向他推销了一下。
And at the end of it, he's like, okay, man, let's do this. And that was like a year or two before, we started working on it together a year or two before we ever shot it. Was it always gonna be HBO? Was HBO, wasn't it? No, we took it out, we shot it and everyone's, HBO kind of was interested sniffing around but everyone else Was like no way. This is no
最后，他说：好吧，老兄，我们干吧。那是开拍前一年或两年，我们在正式开拍前一两年就开始一起合作了。这从一开始就注定是HBO的剧吗？是HBO的，对吧？不，我们拿出去推销，我们拍了，然后每个人，HBO有点感兴趣并开始打探，但其他所有人
No one wants to see someone cut off their arm in the first ten minutes of a show, you know and and and and Francis was like Francesco was like Who was running or say yeah for chance of course he was like, Francesco was like, who was running the television. But yeah, Francesco was like, wait, no one else wants it? I'm like, no, she's like, okay, we'll do it. Yeah, she's a badass. That's so cool.
都觉得：没门。这根本不……没有人想看到有人在剧集的前十分钟砍掉自己的胳膊，你知道的，而且，而且，弗朗西斯当时就像是……谁在运营或说，对，当然是弗朗西斯，她当时就像是，弗朗西斯就像是，谁在运营电视台。但是，对，弗朗西斯就像是：等等，没人想要它？我说：不，她就说：好吧，我们来做。是的，她是个狠角色。太酷了。
Yeah, that's so cool. And we did it. But Derek had the genius idea. It was really, he really approached it as two different films really. And he said, I want you to go out and gain the weight and we're gonna take eight weeks and you're gonna, yeah, I was like, no gym, weight gain.
是的，太酷了。我们做到了。但德里克有个天才的想法。真的，他真的是把它当作两部不同的电影来对待的。他说：我希望你出去增肥，我们会花八周时间，然后你，对，我当时想：不上健身房，只管长胖。
Sign me up. Yeah, exactly. And that was really like having the space between that. And you know, usually you do a twin movie and literally you run off, you put a mustache on, you run back in the same day and you shoot it. But I got- Well, that's how you did Lego Masters this year, right?
算我一个。对，没错了。这真的就像在中间留出空间一样。你知道的，通常你拍双胞胎电影时，字面上看就是你跑开，贴上假胡子，同一天跑回来再拍。但我得到了——嗯，这就是你今年做《乐高大师》的方法，对吧？
That's exactly how I did everything. Glue it on, my spirit on, let's tamp it down. Well, I just, and I just used clippings from my wig. Yeah. And you're so damn good. And I hate use clippings for my wig. Yeah. And you're so damn good. And I hate you for that because I have to take eight weeks to get my shit together and grow on what's that. So beautiful. Wow.
这正是我做所有事情的方法。黏上去，贴上我的精神，把它压紧。好吧，我只是，我只是用了我的假发剪下来的碎发。对。你演得太棒了。我为此恨你，因为我得花八周时间把我的状态调整好，还要长出……太美了。哇。
I know. Your performance deserved the nomination. Thank you. Just incredible. And of course, because you're sitting here and I'm a huge fan of the Marvel stuff and how did you get the Hulk? When I see what you guys do in the Marvel movies, I'm just like, you know, not having done a ton of movies myself, but enough to know that the schedules are like 15, 16 hours a day. But those I imagine where you shoot like,
我知道。你的表演配得上提名。谢谢。简直不可思议。当然，因为你坐在这里，而我是漫威电影的超级粉丝，你是怎么拿到“绿巨人”这个角色的？当我看到你们在漫威电影里所做的事情时，我就会想（你知道的，虽然我自己没演过很多电影，但足够知道）：日程表大约是每天15、16个小时。但我想象那些地方你们拍的时候，
well, let's shoot like three lines of dialogue today. That's what it feels like from the outside. Like there's so much time and money. It just must be so cushy. Meanwhile, you spent three hours in the makeup chair before you even do that. Downey says he won't do more than three words a day, I heard. Well, he's on a per-world rate. That's when he's busting his ass.
嗯，今天我们就拍三行台词吧。从外面看起来就是这种感觉。感觉有那么多的时间和金钱。那一定很舒服。与此同时，你在化妆椅上坐了三个小时，甚至还没开始演呢。我听说唐尼说他一天绝不说超过三个词。嗯，他是按世界费率拿钱的。那是他拼命干的时候。
Yeah, that's when he's working his hardest. Why would I do more than three? Oh yeah. Actually, Downey could probably do 10 pages of dialogue in a day. Oh yeah. I mean, he speaks quickly. And the guy, I mean, it's just,
对，那是他工作最努力的时候。我为什么要说超过三个？哦，对了。事实上，唐尼一天大概能演10页台词。哦，真的。我是说，他语速很快。而且这家伙，我是说，简直是……
I don't understand how he does it. He's a genius. It's just amazing. He's a genius. It takes me like a month to learn a line. Truly. And so, oh God, it takes me forever. It's such a drag.
我不明白他是怎么做到的。他是个天才。太惊人了。他是个天才。我得花一个月的时间来记一句台词。真的。所以，天哪，我花的时间太长了。这真是个累赘。
Really? Do you have like a trick? Like some people write their lines down. That makes them remember it. Others like kind of say it into a mirror. Do you have a way? I have this app called Scene Study. Really?
真的吗？你有什么诀窍吗？有些人把台词写下来。这能帮他们记住。另一些人则对着镜子念。你有什么方法吗？我有一个叫“场景研究”的应用程序。真的吗？
And I record each line, and then I could pull out my character's line and it just runs in repetition over and over and over again. And then I just, I'll learn it that way. And what I have to do, it's weird. I have to be walking to learn lines, to really learn them. That's not weird. And I just repeat them over and over and over
我把每一行台词都录下来，然后我可以抽掉我角色的台词，它就会一遍又一遍、反反复复地播放。然后我就这样去记。我必须这样做，这很奇怪。我必须一边走一边记台词，才能真正记住它们。这并不奇怪。我只是把它们重复了一遍又一遍又一遍
a thousand times to learn it like a song kind of, you know? No shit. The way lines go into my head is that I don't decide exactly how I'm going to be saying a line, but I fully sort of understand kind of what I'm saying and why I'm saying it. So there's a little bit of performance that's kind of in there.
上千次，就像学歌一样把它们记住，你知道吗？没开玩笑。台词进入我脑海的方式是，我并没有决定好我具体要怎么说一句台词，但我完全理解了我大概在说什么以及我为什么要这么说。所以里面其实包含了一点表演成分。
Like I can't just learn word, word, word, word, word, period. You know, like it, there needs to be in context or something. So do you marry in a certain amount of performance when you're learning your lines? And if so, are you able to be flexible once you get on the set? And now the other actor is doing it differently
就像我不能只是去记：词、词、词、词、词、句号。你知道的，就像它需要有上下文或者别的什么。所以当你记台词时，你会在其中融入一定量的表演吗？如果是这样的话，一旦你到了片场，而另一个演员用不同的方式来演，
or the director is asking for a different tone and you're unable to pivot your performance because the learning of the line is married to the performance. Does that make sense? Yep, I learned early on, this was a technique that was taught to me from my acting teacher who had learned it
或者导演要求不同的语调，你还能灵活调整你的表演吗，还是说台词的记忆和表演是绑定在一起的？这说得通吗？是的，我早期的时侯学过，这是我的表演老师教给我的一个技巧，他是从
from someone who learned it from Paul Muni. So this technique goes like way back. And the whole thing was is that you just spit it out and you start really slowly at first. So let's say, you know, I, to be or not to be or whatever. So you do it to be or not to be or whatever. So you do it to be or not to be very slowly and you work it up faster and faster and faster to be or not to be, to be or not to be,
一个跟保罗·穆尼学过的人那里学来的。所以这个技巧可以追溯到很久以前。核心内容就是你把它吐出来，一开始语速要非常慢。所以假设，你知道的，我，“生存还是毁灭”或者别的什么。所以你这样做：“生存还是毁灭”或者别的什么。所以你这样做：非常慢地念“生存还是毁灭”，然后你的语速越来越快、越来越快：“生存还是毁灭，生存还是毁灭，
to be or not to be, to be or not to be. And it's really just to teach your muscles to know it without having to think about it. So then when you are working, you're super free. And you haven't really, you've learned it in a way that is like, doesn't have any inflection on it, just very flat. So that you can be more open to what's coming at you and you don't get stuck in a particular way of saying it, although I do anyway.
生存还是毁灭，生存还是毁灭”。这其实只是为了训练你的肌肉记住它，而不需要动脑思考。所以当你在工作时，你会超级自由。你并没有真的，你记住它的方式是没有任何语调起伏的，非常平淡。这样你就能对迎面而来的东西保持开放的心态，不会拘泥于某种特定的说法，尽管我还是会这样。
Isn't it amazing that you make different ways here? The way that you learn it can, if you do it that way, can sometimes affect the cadence. Like, quite literally just to get to the mechanics, the actual cadence of how you say it. I was talking about this yesterday with an actor whom we all know, and he was saying, we were talking about this, and I said about this weird sort of quasi-improved thing
你不觉得神奇吗，你在这里用的是不同的方式？如果你用那种方式学习，有时会影响节奏。字面意思上，就是为了掌握技巧，你说话的实际节奏。我昨天和一个我们大家都知道的演员谈过这个，他说，我们在谈论这个，我说到了这种奇怪的、准即兴的东西，
that we were talking about, and I said, I remember there were people that we worked with. I could count on that person delivering a line. They always delivered it the same way every time. And I knew that they were gonna deliver it that way, which freed me up or us up to do whatever the fuck we wanted because they were just like a spine. They would always do it the same way.
我们当时在讨论这个，我说，我记得我们共事过的一些人。我可以指望那个人说出一句台词。他们每次说台词的方式都一模一样。我知道他们会那样说台词，这让我或我们得以解放，可以去干任何他妈想干的事，因为他们就像一根脊椎。他们总是用同一种方式来演。
So then you could just fuck with that. It was so freeing knowing that they were always gonna be right on it So it didn't matter so I was I've always felt so free to just fuck around no curveballs No, no curveballs. What's really beautiful in your work though, too. It's like, you know That freedom is with is that is that one of the things that you like about theater, the fact that there is dialogue there that you once you learn it, you don't have to learn anything yet. Like there's no new scene tomorrow
所以你就可以围绕着这一点去胡闹了。知道他们一定会稳稳接住，这种感觉太解放了，所以没关系。因此，我一直觉得可以随心所欲地胡闹，没有突发状况。没有，没有突发状况。不过，你的作品里真正美妙的地方也在于，你知道，那种自由在于，那是你喜欢戏剧的原因之一吗？因为那里的台词一旦你学会了，就不用再学别的了。比如明天没有新场景，
and another scene the next day. Yeah, but I would say like Mark, not to get, I know we spent a lot of time on this as our youth, but I mean, you know, and I maybe short of Kenny, I don't know if anybody saw it, especially that first one, more than me. I fucking, that play has so much dialogue, and you specifically have so much dialogue in that play
后天也没有别的场景。是的，但我会说，马克，不是为了纠缠——我知道我们在《这是我们的青春》上花了很长时间——但我是说，你知道的，除了肯尼之外，我不确定有没有人看过它，特别是第一部，比我看过的次数更多。我他妈的，那部话剧里的台词太多了，特别是你在那部话剧里的台词多得
that it's mind blowing. And you guys, it's so crazy. And from previews all the way through the end of the run, your performance changed a lot. It did, it evolved and you were giving like, I mean, you remember, how much dialogue did you have in that fucking play? Oh, so much dialogue.
这简直太让人震惊了。而且你们知道吗，太疯狂了。从试演一直到演出结束，你们的表演经历了很多变化。确实如此，它在不断演变，而且你们当时……我的意思是，你们还记得吗，在那部该死的戏剧里你们有多少台词？哦，台词太多了。
We both, I mean, there's two people literally at stage. Either me and one other person, or me and another person for two hours. But you all the time. And me just all the time. And big monologues and lots of overlapping. So you had to learn the overlapping. And his writing is so crazy.
我们两个，我的意思是，舞台上 literalmente（字面意思）就只有两个人。要么是我和另一个人，要么是我和另其他人，整整两个小时。但是你一直在台上。而我也就是一直都在。有大量的独白，还有很多重叠的台词。所以你们必须掌握好重叠的部分。而且他的剧本太疯狂了。
It's like, yeah, you know what I mean? It's like, I don't know, you know, like. Mm-hmm, like that, yeah. It has so many stops and starts and idiosyncratic, you know, dialogue. And for Tracy out there in theater, you cannot change the dialogue at all, or you get written up by the stage manager, right? And then equity will find you. You can't change anything.
就像是，对吧，你懂我意思吗？就像是，我不知道，你知道的，比如。嗯哼，就像那样，对吧。它有那么多的停顿、开始以及特立独行的、你知道的对话。对于在剧场里混的特蕾西来说，你绝对不能改变台词，否则舞台经理会给你记过，对吧？然后演员工会会罚款你。你什么都不能改。
They're like, why were you changing your, why did you change where you moved on that line? Right. That was set, you know, that was set with a director or. I would sink with that. I'm way too loose with the dialogue. The first act, it was two minutes too long. Yeah, I know.
他们会质问：你为什么要改变你的……你为什么要在句台词上改变走位？对吧。那是排练好的，你知道的，那是和导演商量好的，或者……我会为此崩溃的。我对台词太随性了。第一幕比规定长了两分钟。对，我知道。
So can we just tighten that up again? Yeah. And you're just like, what are you talking? I don't care. And if you really want to get out of there, it's five minutes too short. Exactly. We just talk faster.
所以我们能再把它压缩一下吗？对。而你当时的反应就像是，你在说什么？我不在乎。如果你真的想早点离开那儿，它其实短了五分钟。没错。我们只要说快一点就行了。
No, they never complain about it being too short. Yeah. First of all, have you ever, I read that all your activism and you're using your voice on such a massive platform to use your voice and you're not afraid to use your voice. And I love that about you, your opinions. You just spew them out. This is what I believe.
不，他们从来不会抱怨嫌它太短。对。首先，你有没有……我读到过关于你所有的社会活动，你在如此巨大的平台上为自己发声，你毫不畏惧地发出自己的声音。我非常喜欢你这一点，还有你的观点。你总是脱口而出。这就是我的信仰。
This is what's right from wrong. And I love it. Well, let's just spew them out. I mean, that means it's... No, but I mean, it's like, intelligently... Let's try different rooms that way. No, no, no, no.
这就是是非曲直。我太喜欢了。好吧，那就直接说出来吧。我的意思是，那意味着它是……不，但我的意思是，它就像是，很理智地……我们换个房间试试那种方式。不，不，不，不。
No, it is, yeah, Sean's right. It's remarkable, dude. How much do you have? It is incredible and I love it. And I wish I had the balls you have. But tell me what the solutions project is. But wait, before I talk about the solutions project, have you ever spoken in front of Congress?
不，确实是，肖恩说得对。这太了不起了，老兄。你到底有多少？这太不可思议了，我太喜欢了。我真希望我有你那样的勇气。但请告诉我，“解决方案项目”是什么。不过等等，在我讲解决方案项目之前，你曾在国会面前演讲过吗？
I've spoken on the Hill with the Senate. I've testified. So this is what I want to ask you. What is that like when you're sitting there? Because at home, when I'm watching somebody do that, they all look like bored. And you're like, Scottie, who turned on CNBC? Is it effective?
我在国会山和参议院发表过演讲。我作证过。所以这就是我想问你的。当你坐在那里时，那是什么感觉？因为在家里，当我看着别人做这件事时，他们看起来都无聊透顶。而你会想：斯科特，谁打开了CNBC？这有效吗？
Did you feel like being there was effective? You know, so I did that movie, Dark Waters, which is about forever chemicals for Tracy. They're the chemicals that come from like Teflon that stay in your blood and are linked to seven different cancers and they're in everybody and all over the world and the mother passes it from themselves to the baby through their breast milk and it gets in your body, it accumulates and it never leaves. And it's pervasive. So we did a movie called Dark Waters to tell the story of the lawyer who exposes this.
你觉得身处那里有效吗？你知道的，我拍过那部电影《黑水》，那是关于特蕾西所知道的“永久化学品”的电影。它们是来自特氟龙之类的化学物质，会留在你的血液里，与七种不同的癌症有关，每个人体内都有，全世界到处都是，母亲会通过母乳将它们从自身传给婴儿，它们进入你的体内，不断积累却永远不会消失。而且它们无处不在。所以我们拍了一部名为《黑水的电影》来讲述这位揭露这一真相的律师的故事。
It's a true story and brings all the lawsuits and wins the biggest tort lawsuit in the history of the United States to actually study this stuff. So I was asked to go and testify to the environmental committee. When you go there, it's half Republicans, half Democrats, the seats are like,
这是一个真实的故事，引发了所有的诉讼，并赢得了美国历史上最大的侵权诉讼，以真正研究这些东西。所以我被邀请去环境委员会作证。当你去那里时，一半是共和党人，一半是民主党人，座位就像是……
it's a gallery kind of thing and they're all there. These are house people. I didn't go to the Senate. there. These are house people. I didn't go to the Senate. And you're testifying and they're asking you questions and you're getting peppered a little bit. But on one side, the Democrat side, there was literally, every seat was taken, it was like 40 people. On the Republican side, there's three guys. And when they're done with their questions, they get the hell out of there. Oh, he literally, he wasn't even a question, is like, I know why you're here.
有点像美术馆那种地方，他们都在那儿。 这些是众议院的人。我没去参议院。 那里。这些是众议院的人。我没去参议院。你在作证，他们向你提问，你有点被穷追猛打。但在一边，也就是民主党那边， literalmente（字面意思），每一个座位都坐满了，大概有40个人。在共和党那边，只有三个人。他们问完问题后，立马就滚蛋了。哦，他简直了，甚至都不是一个问题，就好像是，我知道你为什么来。
You hate industry. This is all just a ploy for you to make a bunch of money and attack big corporations and the economic good of people. And that's all I got to say. And threw them like down and walked out. I yield. I yield. Yeah. And I'm like, you wanna get a chance to answer that?
你讨厌工业。这全都是你的把戏，为了赚一大笔钱，攻击大企业和人们的经济利益。这就是我要说的全部。然后把稿子往下一扔，就走人了。我抗辩。我抗辩。是的。然后我就想，你想有机会回答那个问题吗？
I'm like, believe me, I know how to make a movie that makes a lot of money and this is not one of them. Right. Yeah. And there's nothing in here that's erroneous at all. Everything's completely vetted and backed back. I'm sure you've been asked this before so I apologize We're not knowing the answer, but have you ever given any thought to public office? No No, and because of the of the the pain in the ass of it all because of Folks that have different ideas about why they're there?
我就觉得，相信我，我知道怎么拍一部能赚大钱的电影，而这部绝对不是其中之一。对。是的。而且这里面没有任何错误的东西。一切都经过了彻底的审查和支持。我确信以前有人问过你这个问题，所以如果不知道答案我向你道歉，但你有没有考虑过从政？不，没有，因为这实在是太烦人了，因为有些人对他们为什么去那里有着不同的看法？
Yeah, you know, I'd, you know, I was there, I was there lobbying against fracking like back in the day. And when it was all just kind of happening and I was in Harry Reid's office. And basically he didn't come to the meeting, but his chief of staff was there and he said, listen, close the door.
是的，你知道，我，你知道的，我在那儿，我曾经在那儿游说反对压裂采矿，就在过去。当时这一切刚刚发生，我在哈里·里德的办公室。基本上他没来开会，但他的幕僚长在那儿，他说，听着，把门关上。
I said, listen, here's the deal. This city is overrun with fossil fuel money. We have to spend three quarters of our time on the phone raising money. You're in the wrong place. You need to do this on the regional level, on the phone raising money. You're in the wrong place. You need to do this on the regional level, on the state level. That's really where this kind of thing
我说，听着，情况是这样的。这座城市到处都是化石燃料的资金。我们必须把四分之三的时间花在打电话筹款上。你来错地方了。你需要在地区层面上做这件事，在电话上筹款。你来错地方了。你需要在地区层面上做这件事，在州层面上。这才是真正这种事情
is the only place that this could get done. And I was just like, are you kidding? Just heartening. Are you joking me? And the reason they need the money, or any politician needs money, is to buy 30 second ads, right? To get reelected and reelected,
唯一能做成的地方。我当时就想，你在开玩笑吧？真让人泄气。你在逗我吗？他们需要钱的原因，或者任何政治家需要钱的原因，是为了买30秒的广告，对吧？为了不断当选，
which only just puts them in a position of power. It's not like it's some extremely lucrative position to be a senator or a representative. It's, you know, some of them are there for ideological reasons, right? I would imagine, but- Yeah, initially mostly. Yeah, not to be overly cynical,
这只会让他们处于权力地位。当参议员或众议员并不是什么极其赚钱的职位。你知道，他们中有些人是为了意识形态的原因去那里的，对吧？我想是的，但是——是的，最初主要是这样。是的，不是为了表现得过于愤世嫉俗，
but it seems like, or sounds sounds like a lot of them are there just because they enjoy the position of access and influence and power and getting their ring kissed at parties and stuff like that. It's just so heartbreaking. It's pretty like, you know, likely see it's just, you know, it's not really about policy that's gonna help people.
但看起来，或者听起来，他们中的很多人去那里只是因为他们喜欢接触、影响力和权力的地位，喜欢在派对上被人吻手之类的事情。这太让人心碎了。这挺像，你知道的，很可能会看到，这其实并不是为了能帮助人们的政策。
It just gets broken down along sort of these lines. And a lot of them are just ideological. And it's like, I need to get this money from this person so there's a little bit of back and forth. I'm gonna have to give them a little bit of something. And that's really, I mean, I think that's more true than any of us really wanna believe. Yeah, yeah.
它只是顺着这些路线被打破了。他们中的许多人只是出于意识形态。这就好像，我需要从这个人那里得到这笔资金，所以会有一些来回拉扯。我得给他们一点好处。而这真的，我的意思是，我认为这比我们任何人愿意相信的都要真实。对，对。
But if you ran, you could start a change. If a bunch of people like you ran, I guess what I sense from you is that you can really affect. No, but is that you can affect change outside, like that there is no change on the inside and that if you want to make noise or whatever, you have to keep banging the drum from outside. And you can, and you do.
但如果你竞选，你就能引发改变。如果像你这样的一群人去竞选，我想我从你身上感觉到的是，你可以真正产生影响。不，但事实是，你可以在外面产生影响，就像内部没有改变一样，如果你想制造噪音或什么的，你必须一直在外面敲击战鼓。你可以，而且你也做到了。
I mean, we banned fracking here in New York state. And PFAS is finally, you never, you don't really, I mean, we know, but there's such power in storytelling. And you can really change things with storytelling, especially if you're not like nailing it, hitting it on the head, just sort of, just telling that story, that human story that we all relate to, you know?
我的意思是，我们在纽约州禁止了压裂采矿。而PFAS终于，你从不，你其实不，我的意思是，我们知道，但讲故事的力量太强大了。你可以通过讲故事真正改变事情，尤其是如果你没有像敲钉子一样，直击要害，而只是那种，只是讲述那个我们都能产生共鸣的人类故事，你知道吗？
We all relate to other people's stories. And you know, there's been movies that I, the kids are all right, right in the middle of the dialogue on same-sex marriage. I mean, that movie opened people up to be like, oh, gay people have it just as bad as we do. Yeah, exactly. You know, and then hope. Oh, look at Sean's show, Will and Grace,
我们都能对其他人的故事产生共鸣。你知道，有些电影，比如《孩子们都很好》，正处于同性婚姻对话的中心。我的意思是，那部电影让人们敞开心扉，觉得，哦，同性恋者的遭遇其实和我们一样糟糕。对，完全正确。你知道的，然后是希望。哦，看看肖恩的节目《威尔与格蕾丝》，
is one of the first shows that like, Exactly, profound. Oh my God, I'm in love with these characters that are not heterosexual, so I guess people aren't so bad Yes, and it's making me laugh that shift which was the biggest shift societal shift on a on an issue Sean that you guys that was the biggest societal shift on an issue With the largest spread of polling than than any other. Yeah, well, thank you for saying that. And to your point, it's just telling a story. We were just, we weren't batting people over the head
这是最早的节目之一，就像是，完全正确，意义深远。哦天哪，我爱上了这些不是异性恋的角色，所以我想人们其实也没那么坏。是的，这让我笑了，这种转变，这是关于一个问题最大的社会转变，肖恩，你们的那场转变，是所有问题中民调跨度最大的一个。是的，好吧，谢谢你这么说。说到你的观点，这只是在讲一个故事。我们当时只是，我们没有用这个打击人们，
about it, just like presenting the people and the facts. And this is how normal everybody is, you know? And we just, we just, we just frack a little differently. Yeah. Yeah. Fuckin' asshole, that's so good. See, this guy, damn it. This is a big money. How long so good. See, this is great. God damn it. This is a big money.
只是展示人们和事实。每个人都是多么正常，你知道吗？我们只是，我们只是，我们只是用稍微不同的方式进行压裂。对。对。他妈的混蛋，太棒了。看，这家伙，该死。这是一笔大钱。那个有多久，我不知道。铺垫得太美妙了。所以很快，在我们放你走之前，马克。沙托马·拉蒙，我不敢相信你曾在那个酒店当过10年酒保。你曾是那里的酒保。不，不，不。我在那儿做零工。
How long that one, I don't know. Just laid in so beautifully. So really quick, before we let you go, Mark. Shatoma Ramon, I can't believe you were the bartender at that hotel for 10 years. You were the bartender. No, no, no. I was doing pickup work there.
我在另一家叫，我在两家酒吧工作过。我在The Olive工作过，那是一个很受欢迎的小酒吧。我在，是的，我在那儿。是的，在那段期间。我在Smalls工作过，那有点像是一个朋克摇滚酒吧，就在梅尔罗斯大道和高尔街交汇的地方。哇。
I was at another bar called, I was at two bars. I was at the Olive, which was a hot little bar. And I was at, yes, I was there. Yes, during that time. And I was at Smalls, which is kind of like this punk rock, rock and roll bar on the, you know, right where Melrose and Gower met. Wow.
我在Chateau（城堡酒店）做零工，那里当时还没有酒吧。所以我们会去为那里的所有活动搭建一个酒吧。哇，哇，哇。回到这里不是很奇妙吗？你会不会回去然后感叹，哇。
And I was doing pickup work at the Chateau, which didn't have a bar yet. So we'd go in and set up a bar for all the events there. Wow, wow, wow. Isn't that wild to be back? Would you ever go back and be like, wow. Yeah, man, I'm there. And the young guy comes in at the food room service
是啊，兄弟，我坐在那儿。然后那个负责客房送餐的年轻小伙子走进来，他有点看着我，我去给他小费，他就像是，哇，这是一笔巨额小费。天哪，他说，嘿，兄弟，你成功了。然后你会说我开始的地方就是你现在站的地方吗？他们知道，他就像是以前在这儿工作过，不是吗？哦，那太酷了。
and he's kind of looking at me and I go to give him his tip and he's like, wow, that's a huge tip. Man, he's like, hey man, you made it. And then do you say I started right where you are? They know, he's like used to work here, didn't you? Oh, that's cool. And I was like, yeah, he's like, you made it, man.
我当时就说，是的，他就像是，你成功了，兄弟。那太酷了。太酷了。我喜欢那样。杰森和我20多年前在那里吃过午餐。他不记得了。是真的吗？马克，谢谢你，兄弟。那太酷了。太酷了。我喜欢那样。杰森和我20多年前在那里吃过午餐。他不记得了。是真的吗？马克，谢谢你今天来到这里。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
That's cool. That's so cool. I love that. Jason and I had lunch there over 20 years ago. He does not remember it. Is that true? Mark, thank you for it, man. That's cool. That's so cool. I love that. Jason and I had lunch there over 20 years ago. He does not remember it. Is that true? Mark, thank you for being here today. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
我想要在，在你走之前。威尔。我真的不记得了。我正看着你呢。你他妈在说什么？你和桑尼现在结婚多久了？已经好久了。我不是那个意思。
I wanted to, before you go. Will. I truly don't. I'm looking at you right now. What the fuck are you talking about? How long have you and Sonny been married now? It's been forever. I don't mean it that way.
我的意思是，这太棒了。这很多。我们在一起27年了。哦，太棒了。这太惊人了。是的。太惊人了。几个孩子？我们有三个孩子。这太不可思议了。22岁、18岁和16岁。你能相信你的生活吗？不，兄弟。我很酷。你知道，我最大的担忧是当我有一个房子时，我会不会，我会不会有一个住的地方。我的意思是，你知道，那就是，那就像，我只想要一个住的地方。
I mean, it's awesome. It's a lot. We've been together for 27 years. Oh, that's great. That's amazing. Yeah. It's amazing. How many kids? We have three kids. It's incredible. 22, 18 and 16. Can you believe your life? No, man. I'm really cool. You know, my biggest concern was when I have a house, what I'd be, what I have a place to live. I mean, you know, that was like, that was like, I just want a place to live.
我只是不想流落街头。如果我能实现这一点，那就太好了。对，对。现在看看这个。现在就像是，现在看看我的办公室。是的。回溯。我不再修摩托车了。
I just don't want to be in the streets. Like, if I can attain that, that would be great. Yeah, yeah. And now look at this. And now it's like, and now look at my office. Yeah. Slashback. I'm not working on motorcycles anymore.
我告诉你，兄弟，你真的，老实说，你一点都没变。你依然是最好、最有才华的家伙，这种事发生在你身上实至名归。我为你的人生感到高兴。你一直都是个这么棒的家伙。你一直有着这么棒的磁场。每次见到你都让我很高兴。
I tell you what, man, you haven't, honestly, you haven't changed a bit. You're still the nicest, most talented dude and you couldn't happen to him. I'm so happy for your life. You're such a, always been such a great dude. You've always had such a great vibe. And it just makes me happy every time I see you.
这真的是我最喜欢的之一。谢谢你，一直以来。你们所有人，我爱你们。谢谢你们。非常感谢你们做这个节目。我也是，谢谢你们邀请我。马克，谢谢你来到这里。我们很感激。
It's truly one of my favorites. Thank you, all the time. All you guys, I love you. Thank you. So much for doing this show. Me too, thank you for having me. Mark, thank you for being here. We appreciate it.
你在我的名单上待了很久是有原因的，能最终见到你并向你表达赞赏真是太好了，因为我觉得你太棒了。不，这太棒了，你们也很棒。这真的是一段非常美好的时光。威尔，我知道，只是，我知道。我们走了很长，我们走了很长一段路。杰森，你对我也一直这么好，还有肖恩，现在
And you were on my list for a long time for a reason and it's so nice to finally meet you and Gush because I just think you're great. No, it was great and you guys are great. And this is such a, it was such a nice time. And Will, I know, just, I know. We came so, we came such a long way. And Jason, you've always been so kind to me and Sean now
就像现在我们互相认识了，当我们再次见面时就能拥抱对方，还有压裂，你知道的。是的，让我们看看。让我们放慢脚步。兄弟，我迫不及待想看《可怜的东西》。我听说它是，让我们拿到那个链接，让我们拿到那个链接。是的，好吧，我们去弄一个。我要为它付全价，晚间票价。是的，晚间票价。
Like now we know each other and we'll be able to hug when we see each other together and frack, you know Yeah, let's see. Let's take things slow Dude, I can't wait to see poor things. I'm gonna Hear it's fan Let's get that link, let's get that link. Yeah, okay, let's get it. I'm gonna pay for it, full price, evening price. Yeah, evening price.
但很快它就会在，你知道的，网站上上映。是的，但我听说这是一部你可以去大银幕上享受的电影。我们这周去电影院看吧。走吧。走吧，伙计们。聪明的战地之旅。好吧。
But soon it'll be just on the, you know, the site. Yeah, but I hear it's one you can go ahead and enjoy a big screen. Let's go see it in the theater this week. Let's go. Let's go boys. Smart Battlefield trip. All right.
马克，你是最棒的。马克，爱你的。谢谢。谢谢你做这一切。祝你剩下的时间过得愉快。再见，伙计。天哪，这家伙直击我目标的中心。他身上就是有一种如此美好的磁场。那些家伙总是显得那么自信。等等，你说的“那些家伙”是什么意思？哪一个？你知道吗？我把他，我觉得他和克鲁德·厄普还有罗克韦尔
Mark, you're the king. Mark, love. Thanks for. Thanks for doing this. Have a great rest of the day. Bye, buddy. Man, that guy hits me right in the center of my like target. Like there's just such a good vibe about him. Those guys always seem like so confident. Which, what do you mean those guys? Which one? You know what? I put him in, I feel like him, Crude Up and Rockwell
就像是从同一个模子里刻出来的。你会说，这就是为什么他们能成功，因为他们显然超级有才华，但他们也经常有工作，因为你想和他们一起鬼混，他们就是那样。纯粹属于你们的家伙。完全是，而且他非常，他只是非常，
are like, you came out of the same keep on. And you go, that's why they work because they're ultra talented, obviously, but they also work a lot because you wanna hang out like they're just going. It's saltily yours dudes. Totally and he's very, he's just very,
我不知道，他就像是，他太真实了。他不需要刻意表现，也没有任何做作。他真的是那种人。我喜欢他经常被调侃。我们笑死了。有道理，这让人放松。是的。好吧，这是一个过渡，
I don't know, he's like, he's so authentic. He doesn't have to try and there's no pretense. He's really that seed. I love that he gets toned a lot. We're dead. Makes sense, it relaxes people. Yeah. Well, that's a segue into,
你在推销新产品吗？是的，你有一支新笔什么的吗？你有一颗软糖吗？你想卖什么？怎么回事？一支新笔。没人再叫它们电子烟笔了。这真的让人放松。
are you pushing a new product? Yeah, do you have a new pen or something? You got a gummy? You want to sell? What's going on? A new pen. No one's calling them vape pens anymore. It really relaxes people.
这让我想起。深深地吸一口气。不过这是我最喜欢的。谢谢，我们很好。不，他，你知道的，就我的品味而言，关于他所做的事情，最棒的一点是，他是一个不可思议的演员，你从来看不到他在演戏。他从来没有采取这些，你知道的，
Which reminds me. Take a deep, deep breath. This is my favorite though. And thanks, we're good. No, he's, you know, it's pretty awesome about what he does for my taste is that he's this incredible actor that you never see him acting. He's never taking these, you know,
我不知道，这些令人反感的角色大转变，有些演员绝对能做到这一点，真的，我不知道，这些令人反感的角色大转变，有些演员绝对能做到这一点，但我从来不觉得他觉得自己需要这样做。就像只是那种——好吧，他在，对我国来说，他在约翰·古德曼的行列里。我一直在提这个，演员的类别，现在它越来越大了
I don't know, these obnoxious character swings that some actors absolutely can pull off for sure, I don't know, these obnoxious character swings that some actors absolutely can pull off for sure, but I never get the sense that he feels like he needs to. Like just kind of just- Well, he's in the, for me, he's in the John Goodman. I've mentioned this all the time, the category of actors and it's growing now
因为我们身上已经有一些了。他是其中之一。他，无论他演什么，他总是那么棒，对吧？对吧？所以你开始思考，比如，哦，他提到了《孩子们都很好》。然后你会想，哦，他演什么都总是那么棒，对吧？所以你开始思考，你想到了，哦，他的《孩子们都很好》，你会觉得，哦，他在那里面演得真好，还有《狐狸捕手》，
because we've had a few on him. He's one of those. He's, it doesn't matter what he's in, he is always great, eh? Right? So you start thinking like, you think about like, oh, he mentions kids are all right. And you're like, oh, he's in, he is always great, eh? So you start thinking, you think about, oh, his kids are all right, and you're like, oh, he's great in that, and you said Fox catcher,
你会觉得，哦，他在那里面演得真好，然后就像是，你忘了《聚光灯》。哦，他在那里面简直不可思议。真正有才华的电影制作人总是被他吸引，是的。好吧，因为他总是那么棒。这是他关于肯尼对他说的话的故事，比如，你不会成功的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。然后你会说，哦，你在这里面真的很棒。就像他关于肯尼对他说的话的故事，比如，你不会成功的，但我们会觉得，哦，你在这里面真的很棒。
you're like, oh, he's great in that, and they're like, you forget about spotlight. Oh, he's incredible in that. Really talented filmmakers are attracted to him, yeah. Well, because he's always great. It's his story about Kenny saying to him, like, you're not gonna do it, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then you're gonna go, oh, you're really good in this. Like he's his story about Kenny saying to him like, you're not gonna do it, but we're gonna go, oh, you're really good in this.
就像他真的是无法否认的好。那个模仿太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我喜欢和你们一起度过这些日子。我很久没见你们了。这感觉已经很懒散了。我们所有人聚在一起已经有相当长的一段时间了。你本该被禁止为我做这些的。
Like he's just really undeniable. That imitation is so funny. It's so, so funny. I like spending these days with you guys. I haven't seen you in a long time. This feels so lazy already. It's been a real quiet while since we all been together. You should be banned from doing these for me.
我们知道，而且，你知道的，我希望随着日子一天天过去，我们能花更多时间。再见。再见。从今以后正式禁止，再见。Smart。最后。Smart。最后。Smart。最后。Smart。最后。
We know, and it's, you know, I wish we could spend more time as the days go. Bye. Bye. Officially banned going forward, bye. Smart. Last. Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass.
SmartLess是由贝内特·巴里科特、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·奥姆贾尔夫100%有机手工制作的。Smart。最后。SmartLess。这个暂时尚未有评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。
SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbicot, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Omjalf. Smart. Lass. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLass 是 100% 有机产品，由贝内特·巴比科特 (Bennett Barbicot)、迈克尔·格兰特·特里 (Michael Grant Terry) 和罗布·奥姆贾尔夫 (Rob Omjalf) 手工精制而成。Smart。Lass。SmartLess。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。